[Music]
i don't listen to anything i do
i when i do hear my voice it sounds like
fran drescher
and it makes me hate myself oh i don't
think it sounds like fran drescher and i
like your voice it makes me feel
comforted thank you you have an
incredibly soothing voice i've talked
about it before
also the way you talk is sort of um it's
like a pantameter that's incredibly
hypnotic i'm not even joking i'm talking
about this okay like
explain it to me like what you just did
you went yeah like explain it to me
like you just have like a very
interesting intonation and
an odd spacing between words oh my god i
swear no no you're so right
because i swear when i when i do any
kind of role
i have to look at how i talk and realize
that
oh i think the way that i talk in real
life
does not come across across good on
camera because i i put weird spaces
but it's captivating and it's like
because you're like
you think i've glitched because you're
like she's having a stroke i'm on the
edge of my seat
you're so right i do have no one's ever
brought that up to me but i know it
about myself
i i will pause sometimes if i've ever
caught an interview
like if someone's like oh it's on let's
watch it and i'm like wow i pause
weirdly you pause at random times
you're right but in a way that i was
thinking about last night because i was
like
watching a lot of your show uh talk show
appearances and and podcasts and stuff
and i think it's actually just you're
thoughtful
and you just don't talk a mile a minute
like i do and just like puke out
everything like you're actually just
thinking about what you're saying when
you speak
um but i was thinking about it a lot
yesterday that's interesting well i i
think a lot a lot of it is from thinking
about well i gotta
i mean no but i do i i do think
but i think a lot of it has to do with i
do speak fast
but i do take more pauses because i
am more i do second guess what i say and
i want to make sure
i'm saying the right thing and then
what's really disappointing is that when
i don't i'm like i took all those pauses
and i regret everything i said which
happens a lot
i took a bunch of time to think about it
and then i'd like to say
something i regret how do we rewind that
but no there was something captivating
about it like
there's that book the art of seduction
by robert greene and
one of the things he says in order to
seduce people is to kind of talk really
quietly so that they have to lean into
you
oh and i obviously don't see anyone
because i scream when i talk
i actually make them recoil frankly and
i was listening to you last night i was
like i wonder if this is like some kind
of
hypnotic like art of seduction life hack
because i think i would be much more
successful
i think i would i would be the joe rogan
of podcasts if i
if that was some kind of art of
deduction if i knew that but by the way
i might now be you might you now have
just inspired here it is
like you didn't come on my podcast one
of our lights fell on you so you own my
house now if you want to
sue me i like your house i'd like to own
it after you renovate it
so i'm gonna jump around a lot please
but the first thing i always like to ask
people when they come on the show
is if we're friends yes we are friends
you and i are friends
we are friends that we don't hang out a
lot or ever
but like hold on hold on because i first
and
yeah but when we do which was today
um and another an event you know but no
here's a difference
okay yes do we are you one of my closest
friends
no um but what but i could call you at
any point or text you and say
like i need to ask you something on the
reel like what do you think about this
and i can ask you something that needs
to stay private and it will
and if i ever needed you and i could
call you and said like
can you call me back i know you'd call
me back or text me back
there are people that in this business
where you're like oh yeah we're friends
and like i text them and i don't i don't
like i don't really know if they will
but it's because of your character i
know
who you are and how we connect i i know
that
that's why i think of you as a friend
even if we don't really get to hang out
outside of like you know
an event which is it's weird i i think i
feel
very very close to you and there's no
reason for it
it's totally unearned i feel like we
just whether it's through the
the animal connection or just we kind of
came up at the same time like i feel
very close to you and like we have
the same values and i i actually as i
get older
and as we have less and less time when
we get busier and busier and our lives
get crazier and crazier
i value more than ever relationships
where you're like if we don't see each
other for six months
and you call i'm like i know she needs
something and i know if i need something
i can call her
and we can just fucking get right to it
yeah no small talk
no pleasantries no formalities like hey
what do you know about this situation
and that's you so wait would you
consider are we friends
i always ask this just in the beginning
because i know and i'm asking you people
in hollywood are so
i'm asking you now why are you not
answering truly my closest friend
i'm horrified to hear that this is less
formal than i thought
you know it's interesting i have such a
fascinating uh
answer journey with you no i actually
have had resentment at you before
because i think we should be like
really close friends no don't you think
i think that we should be really
and actually hanging out with you today
earlier before this was like oh i want
to do this more
and i think that every time we do hang
out i'm like oh like i just
and i never i always feel like in this
business women are
like pitted against each other in a
weird way and are made to compete with
each other
and are just there's so much weirdness
that i always am like oh this person
probably doesn't want to be my friend or
like oh this person probably doesn't
like me like i have a lot of that
shit i have a ton of that you know yeah
i just assume nobody likes me and nobody
wants to be friends with me
and like don't push it and don't try to
hang out
uh well i definitely i feel like that
there's a thing of um
it's like what are we gonna do
am i interesting enough am i going to be
fun enough or do i have enough money to
hang out with you am i as famous as you
am i like it's like that's how it is for
a lot of people it's like you know i
feel like
you know you meet make friends with
people and
and i think instagram makes me very
nervous about hanging out other people
the way that they show their life how
like how pretty they are all the time or
wow
i see their homes and i'm just like oh i
just don't i'm like this is just
it it does bring up a lot of anxiety and
security and i just think
i also don't think that i could roll
with i'm like i don't know what you're
like a lot of people are off like doing
a lot of
shit and i'm like i don't know if i want
to do that can we just hang out at the
house like do you like
that because i look on instagram it
doesn't look like right it looks like
you only want to be on like yachts and
like huge
like can we just kick it on the couch
and be boring because that's i am
secretly the most boring person on the
planet
who pretends to have a really exciting
life and
i actually am at the point where i don't
even i worry about being friends with
people because when someone does come
into my life now i'm like
this has been false advertising i'm
really not that fun
well you know what i have a a problem
with or not problem with what enza
probably hurting my feelings more is
when i
make friends with people and then we
have hung out and then
then they go and they do something or
have a party and then i'm not invited
and you're like
oh what you know or or i will say this
even though i don't
i've never said this out loud but i
thought of it i was like i don't it's
one of those things where i'm also
insecure about like the things that i
admit
to being insecure about you know because
you don't want to but
like when you're friends you think
you're friends with somebody or you've
worked with them and then like they
don't follow you on instagram
like something small like that where
you're like but they're following all
these other people yeah
and like and then you're falling and
then you're just like it just it's one
of the it's a weird
marker now for like yeah feelings yeah
because especially if somebody is like
following a lot of other people
how close are we but i feel like do you
even like respect me or like me
enough to like you know follow along
with whatever it is i'm doing even
though i feel like you'd like me a lot
more if you didn't follow me
sometimes i wish that i didn't even have
an instagram so there wouldn't be that
marker
right it'd be like oh i want to be that
cool girl that's like i don't even have
an instagram or twitter it's like
i'm just i'm so mysterious yeah i'm not
at all i'm desperate for
love at all costs and will broadcast
every second of my life
um it's interesting you make a ton of
money it's that's correct
uh isn't it weird how when a woman says
that they're gross
i'm not gonna let that happen that was
gross good i'm not gonna let that happen
i'm happy that you make a lot of money
guys can say that guys can be like
making bills and making
and it's like sexy and hot but i think
they're gross
i think it's hot when you're doing it
it's awesome i also
it's so interesting because i have
historically projected a lot onto you
please tell me everything i feel
horrible that that you have
for real this is what have you projected
on this is real i projected a lot on to
you because
i think we kind of came to hollywood at
the same time
don't you think i i came in 2015.
[Laughter]
so whatever it was i remember seeing you
around
and being so at the time i mean i was a
mess
like i was a mess the first time we met
or saw each other or were in the same
concentric circles or whatever
i was such a disaster i was like a
completely unrecovered codependent like
workaholic super insecure hanging by
thread
and i would see you and whether this is
true or not
please i project it on to you like you
were always so together
and so calm and so clear knew what you
wanted and i was just like
always so insecure is something going on
are we good okay um sorry i just have
such a bad
add i know like what happened um and you
were
always so clear and so confident and i
was jealous
wow when did when what year is that were
you any of those things
or did i invent them in my head well
depends on what year
i don't know 2 000 you were probably
doing the show by
my by now your g4 show so well it
depends on when it
was uh-huh because i could tell you but
it depends on what in what room we might
have been in
because there were times when when i
started on g4
i had no idea that that would be the the
key that would unlock you know hollywood
for me right
and so i was just on it and i i had no
real
barometer for like anything that was
happening
and um i was just having fun and it was
really fun and i was just
enjoying my life and i was making money
i remember
you know i remember i called when i got
that job on g4 i remember
the first year they paid me it was uh
like 80 grand
and i thought oh my god i'm so rich
or not forever i never have to work
again i called my mom and i was like mom
i'm done i was like can i borrow your
credit card to go to forever 21
and buy a hundred dollars worth of
clothes to celebrate and i with a
hundred dollars worth of clothes i
bought like seventeen hundred things
yeah i was excited for 50 tube tops yeah
yeah but like
i was just like everything was so
exciting and new and like
that first year did change and um
and i got paid more the show was doing
better
but um i
if you see me during the early years of
g4 i was
like had oblivious i was just oblivious
i was just happy doing my thing yeah
had no idea and then i started getting
more anxiety
when like i uh when i felt that it was
like
it was time like like that the other
things were coming my way other
opportunities
i was getting offered stuff and i didn't
think i was ready for it so i would turn
things down i was like oh gosh i don't
wanna i don't wanna i would turn things
out to stay at g4
and then my anxiety started coming up
but it's so
interesting that for a lot of people
they start out super insecure
and then they get successful and that
cures some of their self-esteem issues
or they look
to external things to meet internal
needs they go i have this thing it's
almost like you were super
confident and then you started working a
lot and the stakes got
got higher and then you started getting
anxious yeah well
the truth is that um it was
it was really tied to the fact that like
now i have i'm getting offers for things
and i can see where this could go and
fuck if i'm what if it goes away like
i'm i'm good right here
and i'm happy here and like this is
comfortable yeah and
and um you know and you know i'm you
know
i'm half asian half white and growing up
as a you know minority
female you know it's it's something that
you know
kind of was ingrained somewhere in my
head was just like
the you know it stacked against me you
know um
stacked against all minorities and then
minority women
and so it was just that that idea that
um it was just going to be maybe it was
just too much for me
and i wouldn't be able to really do i
was really happy where i was also i will
say at the same time
around the time that i in my head of
when i started getting anxiety anxiety
was like
2009 right before i went on to the daily
show with john stewart it was right
before then and i
i was in a relationship with somebody
it's my first time as ever in like
tabloids or anything like that
and that was a completely new thing for
me and i
that put another spotlight on me that i
wasn't prepared for
and um and having you know anybody talk
about me online in a way that was like
before when people i'd say something i'd
say something stupid or whatever i
didn't really care and it was just like
in my you know in the g4 nerd bubble
that i felt very protected in i felt and
i knew those people and that's how my
family was and it just felt like
whatever you know we're all kind of
talking and
and i would you know fumble around but
then all of a sudden there's this other
like the mainstream eye that a
microscope really
yeah and i'm sure like looking back it
was like nothing to other people but
when it's happening to you it really it
felt like oh god oh god and for me at
the time i thought
um it just made me feel like
okay now i i don't now i have
now i have people thinking about me in
this way and they're looking at me and
like
and i think that maybe they think that
like i'm not good enough to be in the
mainstream
you know because i was still on g4 and
um which i loved and also i just felt
like i wasn't
like if i had started off and like my
first job was mad men
they'd been like oh she's an actress and
that's it you know but my first job was
as
a host of this video game technology
network that i loved it's still my like
one of the
most exciting times of my life it's
something i miss every day um and
something i'm so
proud of but at the time it felt like
the world was like oh who is she yeah
yeah you always want to be an actress
but you hosted something first now she
wants to be an actress
yeah it's like that i couldn't like it
was just like i wasn't good at like it
was
that i wasn't good enough to be dating
this guy that's in this mainstream world
and this thing and that that's
and whether i heard that or i just felt
that i don't i can't i don't remember i
don't think i actually read anything
like that
i think that in my head that was my fear
that that's how people would
see me or that's what they would think
or i think that there was probably just
something
like of like who the hell is she and how
did she get him yeah and you're kind of
like well
i mean because you know i'm i'm a nice
person i'm the best
just like i don't know because we met
and you know you just like you think
like a regular
you know scenario like i met this person
at this place we connected and that's
how you start dating yeah
um but instead it was this big question
mark it felt like to me
and then that created this you know
insecurity for a while and then
i have to learn how to you know be in
these
so if you ever saw me probably looking
like like i had my shit together it was
more probably me like
freaking out in my head being like i was
like because
now that i'm older and i look back and
people say to me like you know
i was always like especially when i
started i was like quiet and i was
like focused because i was like okay
it's a female comic i have to work twice
as hard to get half as much and
everyone's gonna think i'm fucking the
more successful comics and there's like
everyone's always gonna say you're
fucking everyone if you've got any
success and let me prove everybody wrong
and i have to change
i had so much pressure on myself and
then people now they're like yeah i met
you 10 years ago and you were like
very aloof and i'm like no i was just
scared i was scared i was terrified i
was insecure and i was terrified i just
think it's so funny to compare notes of
what you
projected onto someone versus what they
when i would see you at hollywood
parties or something you were probably
just like
terrified and i was insecure and going
like oh she's
you know doesn't want to talk to me or
she's so confident or with the stories
we tell ourselves
when we're so inside our own
narcissistic fears and insecurities
100 and i also think that for whatever
reason
there have been you know so many
microaggressions that
get embedded into our heads and
especially as women
yeah um that we are naturally pitted
against each other
yeah you know it's like if i see if you
know i see you it's like it's like a dog
seeing a coyote it's right
oh god this is gonna take me down
oh shit it's like there's somebody else
who's doing comedy who's um
who's pretty and who's nice and who's
smart and
oh okay so then there can only be one of
us always and
always and i think men are raised they
they're
you know in a they're in team sports
that's right you know they
you know i think about a lot we get like
ballet yeah yeah try to
be the soloist but there's something
also i believe in the the
with microaggressions and um and
actually like
truly understanding like where the term
microaggressions you know comes from and
understanding
what that means you can start to to feed
back
into like into your childhood and
realize
like when you are raised a certain way
um and we watch certain movies and tv
shows and we read in magazines or books
and we get this
thing in our head that um our goal is to
basically
find a husband find a man yeah um and
that's what our worth is
um where men have their own worth you
know like so many times i think women
they actually talked to my girlfriend
earlier today
she was saying why is it that like i'm
in these relationships and i feel like
i um like i just give myself so much
into them
and then when it ends he goes off and he
does whatever but i'm just left broken
and like well because typically a lot of
times women we
we put so we put our whole life on hold
to be in this relationship and men don't
do that um and
that's a good thing it's a healthy thing
to keep things going in your life and
have your friendships and your work and
your hobbies
um so i always say relationships
shouldn't come second
yeah i mean because because what are you
adding to the relationship if you don't
have
your own thing but um so it's
it's those um it's that like i think
going back into the microaggression of
like
so men like in in school right this is
gonna seem like a tangent but it's i
know it's not so cute
podcasts are a giant tangent that's the
good news i talk in a very circuitous
way sometimes and
random pausing i love it but so
uh like in high school um
you get a girl who was at a party and
she hooked up with some guy
and the next day um there everyone's
talking about it
and they're like oh she's a slut she's a
whore she's like whatever
and you see the guys are all laughing
and whispering and looking at her and
then the girls
the other girls also kind of turn their
back on her
that happens a lot nobody really rallies
around her because it's kind of like oh
god everyone's talking about you
now imagine there's a guy and some girl
takes
a dick pic of him and she starts to show
it around to her friends
all the guys somehow know to rally
around each other and be like man fuck
that fuck that bitch
fuck her man fuck and then ever and then
the girls are looking at her going well
they're mad at you now okay well we're
i can't believe you did that that's
really kind of messed up and then they
turn back and then so
it's weird that when you flip it around
the girl always stands by herself
no matter which way you flip it but the
guys they they know how to like rally
around each other and
stand there for each other and protect
each other and i don't know why it's not
ingrained in us to do that yeah
um and i think that that's something
that we have to keep working towards and
the really big thing is that for women
especially in our position
um we have to keep pushing that door
open but make sure we hold it open
yeah behind us i think the people in
front of us they're not holding it open
as much you know
um understandably because it's you know
it wasn't really held open for them
it's so interesting and like i think
that because there's been such a
scarcity complex in our business for so
long and because
you know i think for the most part we're
wired for harmony if there's not
scarcity you know if there's only one
slot
of course it's me against you you know
and i think that
um i also think it's important that
women
know that they can disagree and still be
friends that's been a really big
um uh issue for me in writer's rooms or
in any kind of organizations and charity
where it's like
i disagree i think this should happen
and then another one can say i disagree
and i think this should happen go cool
we don't have to hate each other you're
not a bitch
like we can get through this like we can
get through this uncomfortable moment
it's like you know i think we're so
wired to not make anyone feel
uncomfortable and to be apologetic
that women end up being um
sort of like categorizing a disagreement
as like caddy like we've internalized
the sexist jargon of like she's catty
she's a bitch like
we sometimes do it to each other you
know and i even have to check myself for
i'm like oh that was kind of bitchy that
she did that and i'm like i would never
say that if a guy did that
if a guy was clear with me like that i'd
be like oh he's very decisive
and she sent an email that was very curt
and i'm like oh she's being bitchy and
i'm like what was that like i have to
check my own inner monologue about that
i try to just instead of correcting it i
just try to call men bitchy more
instead of saying she's decisive i'm
like you're a bitch and you're a bitch
you're all fucking bitches
like you're so bitchy oh i'm like rare
guys are bickering i'm like oh cute cat
fight
turn around kitty likes to scratch
that time of the month for benton
you also like have actually had a really
big impact on me in a lot of ways
because
i you know obviously came up in comedy
and what happened with you
in the brett ratner situation of and
you're not
cut out whatever you want if you don't
want to talk about any event
when i was reading back through it
yesterday so much of it is like the
nasty shit he said to you the sexist
shit he said to you
the humiliating shit he was saying to
you it's like i learned at such an early
age in this business
you laugh that shit off you pretend it
didn't happen
you come up with a witty quip to
neutralize it or you go back at them
you ignore it you know i have learned
that i have to laugh at
men's nasty i'm gonna put jokes in
quotes
and comments and pretend like it didn't
bother me and
crystallize this like outer shell of
armor
so that their behavior doesn't hurt me
instead of allowing it to hurt me and
saying like that's not okay
right well yeah i mean
that's what we we are conditioned to do
because
if we say hey that's not okay
they get uncomfortable it's just a joke
it's just a joke you know it's just a
joke and then you're like now you're
sensitive
then you're and you made out you made
things uncomfortable and you're a bummer
frankly
you're being a bummer and whatever and
you speaking up is not going to change
the fact this person
will will they'll still get their job
they won't be taken down they won't be
asked to leave the party
they everyone expects you to just deal
with it yeah and in fact
everyone's a little annoyed with you for
making it uncomfortable you should have
just learned how to
how to deal with it and that's why when
the me too movement
happened in 2017 i remember i was on set
in vancouver
and i got to set in these guys um uh
all the the male actors are like oh my
god you hear about weinstein i was like
what and i when they were telling me
about it i just thought
i couldn't believe it was actually like
that there was any kind of it felt
different i felt like
there was a reckoning that was coming it
wasn't that it wasn't going to be just
an article
and then people were going to move on
because the thing that happened with
brett ratner
um the thing that was different than all
the other people who've come forward in
the me too movement is that
with me he actually admitted to to
what he did in 2011
and um and then he had to go into howard
stern
and admit that he lied and say i lied
about olivia mine we never dated we
never fucked i'm really sorry
and then um he he actually
uh had some homophobic comments he made
the week before
he was fired as a producer of the
academy awards the very next day after
he went on to stern
and then i believe i'm doing the math
right in 2014
he got a 350 million dollar financing
deal with warner brothers
and all he did was put his head down
say sorry and it's like the formula for
redemption that a lot of men
go use you know he he put his head down
he came back up was like sorry sorry and
then he aligned himself with some people
that he hurt he did some
uh he did something with glad i think
some commercial for them right
and they go okay that's great cause we
got this big director and we're doing
this and we'll we forgive you
and then he just resumes his place in
line and
no one thinks about that weekend that he
had said
these things about me and lied about me
and how i just all that whole weekend i
just was like
it was one of the worst weekends ever of
just me just hoping and praying and just
keeping my mind going like how can i all
i wanted was my name back
yeah all i wanted was for people to to
to not think that i would have ever
slept with this guy you know because if
you look at him
it's clear that if you're sleeping with
this guy
yeah you're doing it for one reason yeah
because that's what he looks like in my
opinion and
all i wanted was my name back i i wasn't
even hoping that he would just go away
or that he would get fired or anything
bad would happen
because like i didn't think that i could
even hope for that i didn't think that
that was like
on the docket of like things you can
have i'm like i just want my name back
can you just not have done that to me at
all
and um you know i got
some redemption but then realizing on
that monday when he had to admit to it
but then realizing that it didn't really
matter so then
when the metoo movement happened now
this is like six years
from that time that happened which is
not that much time yeah and
all of a sudden people are kind of going
after women for
not speaking up oh now you're speaking
up why don't you say something before
why do you say something before
and i was able to say as a good as an
example to all the women why they didn't
because look he came after me
he said this about me he admitted to
lying about me
and you guys didn't do anything so why
do you think any of them would ever
speak up yeah
because it didn't didn't matter when it
happened to me and at the time i was
like the
first female correspondent on the daily
show um in seven years before samantha b
and then there was me and so i was in a
good place i was in a place that women
should rally around and and be there to
support
but no no no men or women or or animals
or anybody i was just completely by
myself
just trying to like get my name back so
why do you think any woman ever would
have spoken out
yeah it because nobody gave a shit
nobody cared and and when it's so
interesting because brett ratner like
i look back and it breaks my heart to
think about like all these man weinstein
that like when i moved to l.a it was
like the joke
like you have to fuck harvey weinstein
you're gonna go meet harvey weinstein
grab your knee pads like
the level of you know desensitized the
women that were
older than me would just joke about it
like it was they just
had to cope and it was just like um
you know brett ratner same thing was
like oh he's scummy he's this like i
mean
he said disgusting shit to me all the
time came up he dated people i knew was
awful with them and it's just like oh
that's how it is
the fact that we have had to just
accept it the idea of it changing was
like like
didn't even cross my mind certainly in
my lifetime that i would ever see
someone like that lose power
you know it was just like this is what
we do we degrade ourselves we allow them
to say this shit we allow them to like
grab our bodies and poke us and like say
nasty shit and it's just like
don't be a bummer you know and then when
i
when i do talk to people and they're
like well why did it take so and so so
long to come forward it's like
can you imagine if i had wanted to say
something
15 years ago like who am i going to call
who i'm i've been i'm on two vh1 clip
shows
who what am i going to call you like
fucking tom from myspace like who do i
know
who like i don't know i don't have any
power no one cares
no one's gonna listen to me no one's
gonna believe me they're not gonna
believe me then they're not gonna
believe me now it's just like
it's it's so interesting when
someone wants to say well why didn't
they speak up sooner well they didn't
have any power to speak up where would
they have spoken up and i will say
what's really
it's been very important for me um as
a silence breaker um and for people who
don't know what silence breaker is it's
the people who have broken the silence
on an abuser um the people that created
this movement
the people that spoke out about
weinstein in the beginning that started
this whole thing
um they have been pushed out of their
career
they never got their career started um
they
are all struggling um and um or have
decided to leave our our business all
together because it was
that dramatic for them um it wasn't the
the huge a-list stars that said me too
afterwards me too is a very important
thing because it didn't leave those
women alone yeah
but those women because of their bravery
to come forward and tell these stories
now
and go to the new york times and the l.a
times and tell these stories that's the
only reason why we have this movement
and it's so important that people
know who they are yeah because they have
been pushed aside
um because other big famous women
um are now uh you know on the covers of
magazines being called an advocate
you know and there's a huge difference
between
um someone who advocates and someone who
is an advocate
that's right because the someone who is
just an advocate those are the people on
the covers of the magazines and they do
not know the names they don't know who
jessica barth is or carrie claus and
kaligi you know they don't know these
names
they are advocates you want you can be
an advocate and you can advocate
but um the problem that i've had that
that's get that's
given me the most sleepless nights is
that is all of my conversations with the
silence breakers now
i don't have that issue um i you know
because of whatever in my position that
i get that credit
but um i am not the bravest one out of
all of them
you know and and i hear that
i respect that however having
in the last month had to make a
statement
about someone you know in my life that
was engaging in predatory behavior like
i
have a i mean i i can't
you are such a fucking gangster when it
comes to this shit it is so
clear to you like i remember going when
all the stuff with predator happened
yeah which the
irony that that's what the movie was
called when
um the director hired a
sex offender to be in a scene with you
can you just talk to me about
the what happened between the time you
found out that you had been in a scene
with
someone who was a sex offender to a 14
year old
and when that call to the studio went
like what did that look like
when you made that decision to do that
so
since i spoke out in 2017
um i will be asked by different
journalists from different
news outlets to talk to different women
who want to come forward
about someone a lot of times these women
are afraid
that there's going to be repercussion or
there's lawsuits and so
they want to talk to me and i do a lot
of those calls and
truthfully there's a lot of the calls
where i'll i'll say to them
like i i hear you and i'm really sorry
that that
that that happened to you but if he
wasn't famous
um there's not a story there yeah
and you know you made a bad decision and
i'm not saying that
you know that it's not it doesn't suck
yeah but
you were of age and yes he may be 20 or
30 years older than you yeah but
you shouldn't go forward with this um
it's going to be bad for you it's gonna
be bad for this person and
it's gonna be bad for the movement but
do what you want that's my opinion yeah
so i do that a lot
and a lot of people don't understand the
the how complicated it is
to speak out against someone you're
dealing with like possible lawsuits with
blasphemy
defamation of character slander like it
goes on and on and on the
how much more danger you're putting
yourself in however
um side note that people should
understand if you ever hear stories that
come out in
news news outlets like l.a times new
york times buzzfeed
any anywhere where they're telling these
when an organization is telling a story
they are putting themselves on the line
that's right so
they have to vet out these stories so
hardcore with their lawyers so if you
ever hear a story about this
possible abuser know that the story is
99.9999
true because this huge organization who
could face a massive lawsuit is behind
it and
if you haven't heard of anybody suing
for defamation
then know that that person is guilty
yeah
because if somebody was to say something
about me and said that you know
anything bad like that i would come
after them yeah for defamation yes i'm
like you can't prove this yes
um and so far we don't have that you
know
it's it hasn't happened yeah so um in
fact brett ratner did try to go after
l.a times no i was part of the la times
when he went after this woman who
actually told her story first on
facebook
so she wasn't protected by that so right
um and then
what happens there is it's her own money
but then she we did get her a pro bono
lawyer
and they ended up doing something out of
court settling something
but um but other ones that you've heard
of
all these big ones you've heard about um
you know no one has been sued for
defamation for speaking out
so um i will say to women
whoever you know i speak to i listen to
the story and i
i just think like there's a few things
like
one it doesn't matter so much if i
believe it
i'm just i look for a certain facts like
who like were you underage
did they abuse their power did they rape
you or sexually assault you
in any other way um you know
and okay then if it is yes to any of
those then did you
um tell anybody do you have receipts do
you can you prove this
beyond you just telling me the story and
if you can't prove it
you shouldn't go forward because they're
probably not going to run it anyways
because
the they can't yeah and you are going to
get
um into trouble so and it's not going to
help anybody and i'm really really sorry
yeah but somebody put me on um
a call with uh with someone who was
telling me a story
and about um
about
[Laughter]
another story and what they had been um
around someone who has a lot of young
girls around them
and i said look how old
are you i'm sure i do comedy with them
yeah i said how old are you
and they said um 18 at the time
this happened and i said and they're
like my friends was 19 and
and um these are canadian girls who
told me that they were um they were
coerced to come
to parties house parties um by saying
that they'll help them get their
visa or help them get into the sag union
if they would just come to these parties
and it's really sleazy really gross
and horrible i said but you were of age
okay and did you work for them no so
it's not an abuse of power
is it creepy 100 is this person i'm sure
that's you know
this person is probably doing stuff that
you know is not okay
but with you as the source like you
can't prove it you shouldn't go forward
and then she said well
um what if i know about
a director who um hangs out with a
registered sex offender
and i said well what are you talking
about
and they said oh well
this director is my director on a
predator
his best friend is um
this guy who was a registered sex
offender and
and she tells me his name and i
i'm on the phone and then the person
connecting me to this call
is on the phone as well because they're
like just you know listening in
and i google it and i went oh my god and
then the
reporter googles it too and i'm like oh
god and i was like um
and then the report is like he was in
your movie and i'm like uh-huh
okay um and i said all right well
this is another story i was like well i
gotta you know i have to
get into this now um but you know
thank you for talking thank you for
telling me that and i don't think that
they even connect they didn't connect
they didn't know that he was in the
movie um they think they were just kind
of throwing it out there yeah
i think they wanted to help like expose
more people right so they're like well
we know this story we know the story so
um as soon as i saw that i went into a
deep dive to make sure what i was saying
was correct and it was
right there plain as day and uh and so
then i
i got off the phone called my
lawyer and my manager right away and i
told them and this guy
his his scenes were with me
his scenes were it was the introduction
to my character in the movie which you'd
already shot which i'd already shot
in fact we were just um like
five days away from me presenting at the
mtv vma awards
um and where they're doing a big
predator promotion so we were like super
close to like i think it was that five
days or anyways i know there was like
five days away from picture lock
like we're not making a documentary yeah
it's supposed to be yes
so we were so we i know that we were
really close to
i think no that was what that was it
because on a wednesday i found this out
and then um i said we need to tell them
to delete that scene
and then my lawyer called them
told them this information and i didn't
hear anything for two days
and then on friday i had my
reps call again and say like what's
what's going on because she's supposed
to be at the vmas on sunday and if
you guys don't take this out she's not
gonna promote it and that was something
really important to me because
you know if this guy is using any kind
of fame or platform in
any way to seduce young girls like
he can't do it next to me like i just
won't let if anybody is watching that
things that i endorse this guy i don't
yeah but by stan you know
because when you looked at his instagram
he was in um iron man
3 and he's always got pictures on his
instagram of that he's got he was in the
nice guys he's got a picture of
himself with russell crowe and uh ryan
gosling
and so if some young girl somewhere is
saying this they're going to think oh
he's somebody
okay and so i said i just i won't
promote the movie
if you don't take it out so they said
we're gonna take it out but we can't
reshoot any of her stuff because we do a
picture lock in china on monday and
there's no time to shoot anything new
so i'm like so i don't get that scene at
all they're like no we're just going to
jump in on your character on this other
scene yeah
and it's like okay well you know again
you just take the hit
it's like that's all right fine you'll
you know as long as he's out
and then um and then
i made sure to call my co-stars
i wanted them to know all male co-stars
i wanted them to know
what happened because the way i found
out i knew that
i couldn't keep it under wraps
and i just didn't want them to be
blindsided the way that i was blindsided
yeah yeah
so i told them all and then um it was
just like i don't know if this is gonna
get out i don't know what's gonna happen
but
they did you know all the guys were
really really
you know grateful that i called and were
happy to hear that the scene had been
removed
and and then
i get a call from my manager and they're
like uh so we get a call from the studio
and they're like um why is olivia
calling her co-stars and telling them
about this don't eat okay this is gonna
make me so mad
because like like because uh
what what are we what are you what are
you we're not children what are you
talking about we have each other's phone
numbers this drives me fucking
yeah nuts okay that's such a sexist
thing like
look at women are spreading gossip
they're snitching like what are you
talking about
a woman who called i mean even which is
even worse like it's even worse yeah
yeah yeah yeah but so that's what what
the whole thing is so frustrating and
you're just and he says she says to my
manager
um she says i need you to tell olivia to
grow the fuck up
tell her to grow the fuck up help us get
this movie out without causing any more
waves
and when he called me and told me that i
was like
my first thought was by the way first of
all and as i'm
thinking i'm going oh olivia's the only
adult in this scenario
yeah you're you're not the one that
needs to grow up you're the only one
acting like an adult
i didn't put this motherfucker in the
movie yeah yeah yeah in fact
i helped save the fucking movie because
if i didn't tell you you could picture
lock in china
and then we'd be like opening up toronto
film festival in two weeks which by the
way it's there's
so many people whose only job it is to
make sure there's no
sexual predators in the movie well i
actually found out i found out
um because fox um told us
because i was wondering what happened
apparently in the state of california
it you do not have to do a background
check
it's not um required so they
they're like that's not our fault um and
you know and i guess
you know you never thought that the
director would put his best friend who
is this registered sex offender
into the movie and so maybe nobody
really thought that but yeah you
you know but it's still there should be
people's jobs
to to make sure that this is you know
because we have we had you know a young
kid
in the movie and then he has little
sisters who are around and yeah he's
hanging out and this guy this
particular guys um he did his scene with
me
he was really i was really i was really
uncomfortable being around him
in fact it was like a short scene like a
five-page scene
or something and i remember um the
director said that we should
we should rehearse together now normally
you don't really need to rehearse like
a small scene like that with somebody
who's coming in for you know one day
yeah
um but i was like okay you know i'm
always down to like want to work out the
scene and
work everything out i love you know that
process
and um and this guy comes over to
the apartment that i was renting in
vancouver and it was just so
he was unbelievably uncomfortable i felt
so uncomfortable being around him he was
you know uh not leaving he was there for
hours and hours and it just was so
uncomfortable but you just you know as
he just kind of i didn't feel unsafe but
i just felt like
he was just super sleazy but your gut
knows you know this is why we talk about
this gift the gift of fear
on the podcast all the time about like
how
you know we are so brilliantly designed
to be able to
feel someone being ookie but our brains
talk ourselves out of it because you're
like oh well this person would never be
working here if they were really a bad
person or i must just be
being sensitive or i'm just being
dramatic because that's sort of the
narrative that we are
conditioned to believe as women that
we're you know
overreacting and we're crazy and we're
psycho but um
in the gift of fear um there are these
interviews with women that were attacked
uh by men in you know parking lots and
in apartment buildings and stuff like
that
and they always say i knew there was
something weird about that guy
i fucking knew it and i talked myself
out of it because he offered to help me
carry my groceries and open the door for
me and i was like stop being so crazy
he's super nice you're being dramatic
you're being paranoid and they were
always right um i had a male therapist
say once that i thought it really
changed things in my head to understand
and hear it he said
women do have um
another sense that men don't have
he's like and that's just because we've
had to cultivate it and and and use it
our whole life he's like so
as long as we were on this earth and
we're you know these little kids there's
always been an entire group of people
who are bigger than us yeah so when
we're playing around on the playground
and some boy runs by us we have to think
okay he's running towards us we got to
brace ourselves where he runs another
boy he's strong enough to kind of hold
himself and not fall over or fall you
know
fall down um we get older like say we're
13 years old and we're walking down a
dark alley
um we our senses come up we have to look
at
everything that's around us but you have
a 13-year-old boy he's gonna just
innately because he's grown up feeling
stronger that he's gonna he can
or been told he was stronger you know
but he also but they physically are
you know they grow up being bigger than
us for a certain point then there's a
point where we kind of get bigger than
them for a little bit but they're
but they they are just they don't
have that fear put into them it's
actually a great thing for us
to know so when they go through that
dark alley they just kind of walk
through they don't think anything of it
but for us our spidey senses come
on and we've had to cultivate that and
so that's a really great thing so we
just have to learn as women
that we have this ability and to
really tune into it superpower and to
not have to be shamed about it or
stigmatized about it or pathologize it
you know it's like for me i was talking
to somebody
uh the other day about you know we're in
a pandemic and
people are trying to tour and etc and
there was someone that i know that was
asked to go on a tour and she just felt
weird about it and she was just like it
doesn't feel like it's safe yet and it's
like that's
you don't have to explain why just the
answer is no
i'm really big on saying no to something
i'm not sure why yet i can't articulate
it my gut my inner child whatever you
want to call it my spidey sense
is telling me the answer is no i can
rationalize why i should i can talk
myself out of it but
the answer is no and i'll explain why
later
or my gut should be enough of a reason
why
that's enough evidence for me just my my
body gets to make decisions now instead
of my brain
because my brain will always talk myself
out of any of my emotions and i can
you know be cerebral and talk myself in
and out of
you know bad situations but my big thing
now is just like no
the answer is no my body just said no i
don't even ask my brain anymore well
it's important
the brain is important because you know
the brain supports the heart
and the gut and the gut supports the
brain you know like they they work
together
and sometimes you know i think people
you know you we can
get into a feeling of nobody wants me to
be afraid or nobody wants me to say no
so i'm gonna
so we have to kind of really learn to to
to decipher what's going on and we have
to
understand that our brain is there to
support the rest of our body too it's
not
you know it's it's not just a one-way
street you know you can't just only
trust your gut you know i think it's
important that because
because what happens after a while is we
get conditioned to think
nobody wants to hear us we can't say no
we can't say that's right
but you know like for me i do think
about these things a lot probably
like more than i i should and i do think
about that's probably why i pause when i
talk i do think that
i do think about these types of things a
lot i think about
um so when they when they happen like
when this happened with
with the predator um
it was like it was just it was
it was a the way it all went down the
way it was handled was like
hard it was really hard for me and um
but i wasn't it it was really hard but i
didn't feel blindsided because i had
already i've already thought so much
in my head about how how our voice is
interpreted by other people how our
actions are interpreted by other people
men and women
how it is being a woman how does being a
minority woman how it you know it's
there's all those things that like i've
already thought someone was happening i
just kind of
i you know i braced myself and
and was ready to kind of like lose
everything
before for what i believed was the
the right thing you know you have to i
truly believe and i do act on this i
i do the right thing no matter what can
i tell you something
that is exactly who the fuck you are
and it is so clear and it is so badass
and i i really when i went through
something over the last month like i
very much felt myself like i thought
about you a lot i channeled you a lot
because when the predator stuff happened
i went and watched an interview you gave
somewhere i was like trying to figure
out what was going on it was like in the
new
and you were it was clear you were
stressed in the interview
because i know you and i know enough to
know that your energy is effervescent
and you're
playful and you're buoyant and you're i
just remember you were like and i know
the press junket circuit like i could
tell you were tired
and you were tired of fucking talking
about it and you were
that your cast mates were not supporting
you publicly or
you know and you just went someone's
like why did you do this and you're like
it's very clear
if someone harms children or animals i'm
gonna do something about it
like you just it was like what you
literally were like why what are we
talking about yeah
it's like the fact that it's you know
and
you're an outlier for doing this that's
the conversation that's what's crazy
that's what's newsworthy yeah and you
found i was watching you
and you were like why am i having to
explain myself someone hurt a child
like of course i'm gonna do this to you
it's so obvious
yeah what the right decision is it yeah
i mean it just that's you know that's
how my mom raised us
and that's just how i am and you know
and at the end of the day
like the fear of speaking up
um what could i lose i could lose my
career yeah
i could lose um any kind of income um
i could lose any kind of status i've
created or any kind of
um cultural currency and they can just
take it all away in
in some way um and i could have nothing
yeah
um but the things that i do value
truly value my my family my family's
love their respect for me
my friends my education my
sense of self my self-worth
that's not on the table no one can ever
take that away so once
i i'm you know able to
to understand what that is which was you
know years ago and i realized this
is this is what's important to me then
nothing's really scary
yeah it doesn't mean that that wasn't
really hard and i didn't go you know
during that press junket
you know when i was in the toronto film
festival every night i'd go home and cry
in the hotel
room and have to like you know wash my
face in the morning and
and do it again because i knew that it
was important for me to
like when i did those interviews it's
important for me to be
collected um to not be angry
to not be emotional but to give out the
information
and to answer the questions clearly
because i wanted people to understand
why it was important
that i was speaking up why i wasn't
creating a mess and i wasn't being
dramatic why this
was very simple but also i wanted other
people to
be able to see that and um and say like
oh
you can speak out without without
ruining yourself
that's right and without unraveling and
the the message is not going to get lost
in the delivery of the message
i'm realizing i have so much anger
coming up about this like because it's
like
not only do we have to be the victims of
this we also have to fix it
and we have to speak out about it and
then we have to like speak out about it
in the perfect way and we have to be
composed and we can't be too emotional
we can't be too upset you know when this
happened
you know with uh crystalia it was like
it happened as if the devastation wasn't
enough
then it's like the pressure to say
something
and then if i said something too soon it
would be i didn't say the right thing
or it's def it comes off defensive or it
was like just the mental gymnastics the
six it was literally like six stays
straight of
trying to figure out how to digest
everything into five sentences so people
could actually hear it the way it was
intended and not filter it through their
and i realized something that i got to
the point where i was like you know what
you either fuck with me or you don't
right
and there is no way that me being the
person i've
consistently always been in this moment
i'm not going to lose you or again you
and if i lose you i never had you and
you never fucked with me
if you think this is a controversial
statement
we don't fuck with each other and like
that's fine and i
i got so much thrown at me after that
and there was such
a crazy amount of negativity that came
at me i was like no you guys never
fucked with me
that negativity was always there you
never liked me for whatever reason
i'm a loud mouth female comic we're the
most hated people on the planet like
you know i didn't lose anyone you know
and i think that anyone you do lose when
you're being
your authentic self like either i've
been fake this whole time
yeah and i'm growing and changing or you
just never knew me
well that's you know um i
you know one i will say this you know
you and i were texting a lot during that
yeah and i
um when you i was not sure
you know i i want to be there to be a
support for you but the end of the day
it's like it's what's your statement
going to be and your statement was
is pretty close to fucking flawless in
my opinion that's very nice
and it what and i know how hard that is
you know and i think if i remember
correctly
telling you like you know just take your
time because whatever you say it's gonna
you know
they people can wait for that you you
really helped me
not pull the trigger too soon because i
did feel this sense of urgency to say
something
and my thing is you know me what you say
say what you mean don't say it mean
and wait for the urgency to lift so that
you can be clear and rational because
it's like in moments like that
i feel this pressure of like don't be
dramatic
don't be crazy people already think
women are emotional you have to sound
objective you have to be composed you
have to be mature you have to be clear
and by the way like i know that that's
frustrating
for for us to have to think like that
but that's okay yeah and we're not going
to change the fact that we have to think
about all those things before we make a
statement
that's just how the world is right now
and there are you know there are some
people
that in my belief i feel like there are
some people who are
meant to weather a storm and to get
through to the other side
and then i believe that there are other
people who
are meant to turn around
walk right back into the rain and change
the entire course of the storm
and i think that's somebody like you you
know it you can make it through and get
to the other side and put your head down
and that's fine too like there's some
people that just aren't built
for the controversy or to
actually understand how it is to to
change a storm
and sometimes you get in there and you
can't fucking change it and it's and
it's all that energy for nothing but
if you have the ability to and if you
have the the intelligence to and the
strength to and the support system to
then you gotta turn around and you and
and and go right back in
and try to change it because there are
other people right behind you that you
have to change it for
that's right and if it you know it's not
just for you it's for everyone else and
so when you
do that when you did what you did you
had to take that time
you had to take that time because you
know the people will forget how much
time it took you
unless you took like months right yeah
yeah yeah but they will always remember
what you said
you told me that and people will they'll
and what you said was
it was like i said when i saw it i was
like that's fucking flawless on a you
know another one and not to put him on
not to put her on blast but enough time
has gone by and i think it's an
important
um thing to understand um especially
speaking about like what you did but
like back
when lena dunham just defended her um
the writer that was called out right
um i saw that and immediately texted her
and i said
um because i didn't want to go on to
twitter and respond back i will go
directly to the person
and i said hey like i really respect how
you want to stand up for
your friend and somebody who wrote for
you and um
but i would encourage you to put out um
to delete that statement to put out
another statement because
your experience with him cannot be
compared to others
yeah and where you are right now in your
career and the platform that you have
you are
risking opening a door for other people
to defend simply based on their own
experience
and i think you should put out another
statement and she responds right back
and she said you know oh my god you're
so right
i'll i'll get on to it she did that
actually the next day there was too much
time and she got
you know an onslaught of like of that of
like
what the hell basically what i'd you
know what the pro what i saw was a
problem which is
you can't say that this you know if
somebody has gone forward to the you
know
at this moment in the movement and we
were in the me too movement
let that work itself out and um
and you saying well because as his boss
he never did that to me yeah that's
right
like that's not gonna work and um and
then the next day she did put out a
statement that pretty much said
you know that you're making me realize
something that
you know it's i think that as um
women in this business you're treated
like shit for so long
that by the time you're in a position of
power you might not even know you're in
a position of power
and it took me a while to catch up you
know it took me a while to realize like
what do you mean but
these guys i work with are so nice to me
like they and it's like no there's
people below you that they can treat
like shit it's like
oh there's people below me i thought i
was the lowest
yeah you know like you have to unders
you have to part of our responsibility
as women
you know is to update our software
as we evolve and grow and succeed and
realize like
if you do have power you have to take
responsibility for that you know because
i think as women we're so trainably
we're powerless
you know that it took me a while to
catch up and go like oh yeah my
experience with this person
isn't necessarily everybody's experience
even though my dysmorphia
is not an excuse to not
know what the fuck is going on i that's
i mean i think that's definitely
something that people and women need to
work on i don't think i've ever
um i if anyone has ever
in my life been like this guy's an
asshole
or this girl's a bitch and i'm like and
they're really nice to me i never
i never think i don't believe that i i
think i've
for whatever in my life i think i've
seen enough to be like
yeah that tracks or be like i don't you
know what
i've never seen that in that person but
i can't discount that because i know
that people have so many sides to them
yeah and i can't i
there's no i would never discount what
somebody else tells me yeah um
ever because i can't you know there's a
few people that i would be like
that's you're fucking crazy yeah but
um but like in general like everybody
has so many different sides
and um you know it's also important this
is not the same in the same realm but
it's a little bit of a tangent but
my friend bauwin he directed the bruce
lee documentary that's on 30 for 30.
it was amazing and um and he was asked a
lot um about
uh the controversy with tarantino
representing
bruce lee in once upon a time in
hollywood right because shannon lee
bruce's daughter
who runs the bruce lee legacy um
was really upset by the representation
of bruce in the movie
and she petitioned to have him change it
or delete it and she actually petitioned
and successfully petitioned in china for
him to
not have the movie shown there at all
because china said take out that scene
of bruce lee
or you can't have the movie here at all
so he chose not to delete the scene
um and uh you know bow and i were
talking about it and i
and i was asked a little bit about it
never publicly really i think
just like on instagram kind of thing but
um you know at first he said that you
know bow was like i don't
you know he's trying to be respectful of
an artist like you know
allow quentin tarantino to be the artist
and to do whatever he is he wants to do
because we can't start to
micromanage what artists are putting out
i said however
you know uh tarantino did say
that he researched
talking to people who were around bruce
lee at the time
because he tried to make it as accurate
of a portrayal as he could
so he spoke to people who were around
bruce lee at the time acquaintances or
people on the studio sets or whatever
and they all said that he was this guy
that was arrogant and cocky
and all these things and so just based
on that so now we're no longer talking
about artistry we're not talking about
somebody's own depiction of it
tarantino himself said uh i tried to
make it as believable as possible
now i believe that he was trying to make
that as believable as possible i think
that he was trying to
make an authentic portrayal of bruce lee
and by asking people but i think the one
thing that
he didn't know to put into the equation
was
if you're asking a lot of these these
white men who at the time
you know chinese people were pushed away
and
we were not paid the same and we were
building all the railroads before that
and
you know if all of a sudden you see a
chinese man with confidence
you're going to think that that's cocky
you're going to think that he was
egotistical
and so you have to put into the equation
when you have a memory of somebody like
i remember this guy he was so cocky
yeah but it's also because i was
conditioned at the time that
chinese men should not be um confident
and they should not feel like they can
speak out to any white person out here
so
you know not really that it's like
there's a difference i think sometimes
with
like the racism and those
microaggressions that are put into
people's heads and they you have to
you always have to put into equation how
people are seeing and viewing it
so like when we're talking about the
stuff with um
with like you know how you see things or
how somebody else is saying things we
have to understand like as a female
comedian you're like
well a lot of times these people aren't
don't you you know it's so much harder
right
but a lot of times it's like they they
you have to almost kind of do the
reverse math of it like why
are they like because they don't i don't
it's not i don't think it's a conscious
decision to be like
like fuck you whitney cummings but it's
like okay let's reverse engineer it and
try to understand like why are you
seeing it this way
and then how can we get them to
understand oh yeah i guess i am kind of
doing that right now
i think that's what people are trying to
is with the blm movement people are
trying to
you know to say like you know you've
been doing this really unpack this this
like subconscious shit like i remember
when the constance wu
stuff came out of people were trying to
call her a diva and stuff a friend of
mine
who's asian was like oh that's progress
that someone would think an asian
woman's a diva
because that means she's not being you
know stereotypically silent like that
you know she was joking but it was an
interesting like
oh yeah we're so conditioned to believe
that asian women
are quiet or something or that asian men
aren't you know
sexy and hot and that's right you know
it's but that's because of the
microaggressions
that are in you know film and tv for so
long and so it's
it's like once you have once you
understand how
it was it's like if you have
like mold at your house right and you're
like i got mold and then you're like
okay you can take the mold out but there
was a leak somewhere you got to go
figure out where that leak is that's
creating all of this so we've got to
like you know fix the leak
and then you know and repair all the
drywall and then we can live in this
house again
but until you fix that leak it's going
to get you can take the mold out all you
want
but that leak is going to bring more
mold so you have to like understand the
genesis of it
you are one of the few people in this
business that i'm like
that bitch is not doing it for clout she
is not doing it for likes like she walks
the walk when no one is looking
well thanks and it is it is so rare have
i not said that ben 10
she has said that oh thanks ben you have
to hit the microphone
so loudly when you grab it no i need to
know that i'm here asmr
nightmare um i know i can't keep you too
much longer but i love you you can talk
for longer
how long are podcasts allowed to be i
mean rogan's goes like three hours
but i'm gonna have to stop and pee if we
can i have to pee so okay do you want to
pee yeah
you pee okay let's both people you guys
talk okay benton you take over
okay guys you take over you do because
you're not supposed to edit it the
people don't like an edit and
no you're not she told me we're not
editing this you guys get on get on the
mic
be interesting
okay we're taking a little break from
talking to olivia and we're going to
talk to you about
my favorite product that makes me
feel like a loved wife hellofresh hello
fresh number one meal kit in america
we only mess with number one yes number
one only
hello fresh it's awesome it's a delivery
meal service that basically delivers you
fresh food right to your door i don't
know if benton is allowed to
uh talk about the sponsor since he can't
pronounce the word meal
meal kit it's a meal kid it's a what a
meal kid
meal kit delicious fun easy
affordable meals as benton calls
meals i've been making a lot of the
wasabi zinger salmon i'm not no
dude i don't even know the zinger best
with this company they just send you a
box of ingredients
and then you can just make it yourself
and it's portioned makes me feel like a
magician
yeah makes me feel like a like um uh
it makes me feel like i'm ready to take
rachel ways rachel raise ranger rank
spot any moment rachel race meals
uh there's something for everyone low
calorie vegetarian family friendly
recipes every week
i do i'm addicted to the one that is
just it's salmon asparagus
and how do you pronounce it
dude there's one that is squash
groton is that how you pronounce oh my
god i'm like completely obsessed also
the mushroom ravioli stuff oh you can i
know bento keeps talking about the
mushrooms
i haven't had that one it's so easy to
make it so fast uh
great news contactless delivery
at hellofresh so that you don't have to
worry very safe or be
panicked it's also nice to not have to
go to the grocery store right now i know
that causes a lot of anxiety for people
at least certainly around where i live
you have to wait in line and you have to
put on a mask and also
you can save 28 by using hello fresh
opposed to like grocery store shopping
because when i go
when i go shopping myself i over buy and
then it goes bad
that is very true so this only gives you
the ingredients you need so you don't
have like food going bad
hellofresh's carbon footprint is also 25
percent lower than store-bought garbage
that makes me feel good because i feel
like my carbon footprint has been pretty
sloppy lately so it makes me feel good
that i'm using less
yeah of a carbon footprint uh the
packaging to ship your food is entire
almost entirely made from recyclable
and or recycled content which is
thoughtful fantastic thoughtful frankly
i don't have to feel guilty i'm not as
worried about the sea turtles
i also love the fact that you can add to
your order so you can add extra proteins
you can add
cookies you can add garlic bread yeah
stop it oh
i just want deliveries of garlic bread
pretty much is there an option for that
all day
just a box of garlic bread hellofresh is
committed to making fresh delicious food
available now more than ever and has
taken extra steps to keep its employees
and customers
safe hellofresh donated over 2.5 million
mills
to charity in 2019. that's awesome and
this year is stepping it up
with their food donations amid the
coronavirus crisis
thank you guys that's super cool go to
hellofresh.com
good for you 80 and use the code good
for you 80 to get a total of eighty
dollars
we're giving you 80 basically including
free shipping
on your first box that's hellofresh.com
good for you 80
and use code good for you 80 to get a
total of 80
off including free shipping on your
first guys this is such a good way now
that we can't really go on
a lot of dates during the pandemic to
look like you know how to cook
i'm just i'm just make believe you're on
a date it's a life hack invite him over
for dinner order some hello fr
ello fresh hello friends hello order
some hello fresh and look like you're
uh seasoned
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for more details
i'll fix it so you know that i really
want to learn a new language
me too i'm so sick of english it's
embarrassing
it's so embarrassing and i hardly know
it dude i'm struggling
does babel teach english because i do
think we should retake it i'm tired of
getting all my dialect lessons from
reruns of love island
i decided that i'm going to use babble
to learn swedish
because i want to go to sweden and it's
the most fun language ever
you know how to learn that too you know
how to say yes
yeah it's the closest to furbish so
that's why i want to learn it
furbish but furby speak brah brah
zoe brock c no bar bra
that means how are you bar bra i'm good
ja jump good good job man i think it's
such a fun language yeah
you're really happy saying remember this
one her mardu
her martin that's how are you but you're
with joy right
no that's where is gerard de pardue
in swedish what i just want to learn
swedish so i can get a date with
alexander sarsgaard
that's the real reason to get babble
babble is this amazing
uh company and i just was on their
website today
you can pick how many like what
increments of time you want to study in
every day
15 minutes 30 minutes 60 minutes and it
is proven to get you speaking a language
within weeks
they designed their courses with real
world conversations in mind letting you
learn
every day practical conversations i
remember when i learned french
in high school it was so useless because
they don't teach you conversations
you words yeah you're just like yeah
yeah and then you actually go talk to a
french person they're like that's not
french those are just right
croque monsieur like we don't eat those
anymore that's like from the 20s
uh so these lessons are thoughtfully
created by over 100 language
experts and their teaching methods been
scientifically proven to be effective
across multiple studies choose from 14
different languages
spanish french italian german or in my
case
speedisha babble is available you as
to use an app online god morgan
god morgan that's good that's that's
good morning
in swedish god morgan
god morgan i think that we're putting
like a german yeah i am definitely doing
a german accent
we are not the instructors of babel fyi
right now when you purchase the
three-month subscription baba will give
our listeners three additional months
for
free that's cool with promo code good
for you
job for you for you
that's three editions how embarrassing
that's three additional months free if
you go to babel.com
and use promo code job for you know
on your three-month subscription that's
babble b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
promo code good for you how do you say
as a woman that you have to
go tinkle like what do we do
that's worse than the yogurt on the
tuner of the stereo i have to go take a
piss like i don't even know what i say
i say pee i see we said it i have to go
use the restroom but sometimes
people think i'm saying take a shit like
i'm not gonna take a shit i'm just gonna
go to number one
in the restroom what do you what did he
say i'm just gonna take a peek i'm gonna
go take a peek dude
pop a squat he's gonna have a pee when i
hear p i picture
your vagina being is
like i just think of p i don't think
that's
now you're thinking it i'm thinking
about what your vagina looks like i'm
wondering if it's lasered
it's very lasered it is yeah bald it
looks like a
dolphin yeah did you got we'll get three
guys in here
yeah well um do you have you ever had
sex with a woman
no sorry
some of my gay friends have innocent
questions
and we'll have sex later but i found out
that there are
there are four things that guys think
about the four top things when it comes
to
um well you can guess i'll let you guess
about what about the vagina
it's really far back what
i feel like guys are constantly
surprised by how what
where did it where they just sticking it
like in your belly button
i'm just like i think i think they think
that it's where the penis is which is up
here that's right i really like this i'm
constantly here how far back the vagina
holds
what hold on whitney
what am i i'm just saying
i'm just saying i think it's a common
common
uh plot twist that the vagina is way
further back than maybe you would think
yeah that makes sense whitney do i mean
i think a lot of people think that
you can't be part of this conversation
i've seen mini vaginas
but have you tried to put your penis
into one i think i think that our bodies
were made that it goes like that i feel
like guys
always put their penis like in the front
of the vagina and then just like
push it in you have to like thumb it in
what
guys guys stop looking at your phones
like you don't hear us
is she saying something that is accurate
to your experience
i'm getting a no no okay you've never
had a girlfriend
so you've never had a girl thumb your
penis into her vagina well who would
admit to that
i'm just saying i feel like it's always
further back than it seems
i even sometimes when i put a tampon i'm
like whoa that's so much further back
that i
thought it was gonna be whitney i i
it's my vagina deform it's not deformed
it's just really far back
is your is your butthole on your back is
everything just kind of rotated
butthole are very close you need a good
chiropractor to get your alignment back
you just need to rotate it rotate it
oh my god whitney i okay so your vagina
is very far forward no no no
my vagina isn't a normal vagina place my
vaginal vagina
is like right where it should be i ride
horses maybe it's been pushed back
i don't know maybe i have something i
think you do
you have like a misalignment and you're
like you're t1
5 8 whatever spinal well okay okay so
let's i want you to give me four so one
is that hold on i'm actually really now
sort of
no your vagina's in a normal place don't
you think it's very you've seen my
dinosaur a lot ben had seen my vagina a
lot but have you seen the hole
have you got in there like like uh i
don't think so
you've seen the top of her vagina which
is where he thinks the the hole is
sometimes when i see my friend's
vagina's i'm like my vagina doesn't look
like that
what do your friends you mean in a good
way very wait hold on in a good way or a
bad way
in a like in a way you're like thank god
what no
one time i saw a friend of mine's vagina
that was like oh i want that one
it was like had no it was like like
it was it was wait what was that it was
like it was like
it was like a tiny little um like a
u-shape with just a line in it and that
was it
there was no like i gotta say your
vagina is 10 out of 10. it's a very nice
vagina
as thank you i appreciate it describe it
take your time i have like a labia but
coming out do you know what i mean
barely really yeah
but it's it hides when you come close
it recoils up into my body i think
that's intentional so that you can't
swim oh my god like a turtle head
yeah it's like a roly-poly that just
rolls up i like that that just the labia
being hidden keeps you from being sued
like just that one thing
so okay you were asking me the four
things that guys think about that i have
been told
that guys think about vaginas okay
uh yours was it's not bad i just learned
a lot
um we all learned a lot uh
i mean too much frankly
uh okay the four things people think
about vaginas no people
guys guys not people guys very similar
that they
are guys right size has to be one of
them
that they oh that they stretch
oh i'm so proud of them
well i wouldn't say stretch they don't
str like i'd say the opposite stretch
how tight it is
what is wrong with you wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
what's the game
[Music]
the game is i have been told
by guy guy friends there are four things
that well i deduce them they're like
these are the things that the top things
off the top of their head
they're like when they think about when
they're when they're with a girl for the
first time
sexually and they with her vagina what
are the four
things i thought the four things that
surprised them and i was like
how tight it is i don't think guys have
ever been surprised by that with me
but congratulations i see okay so the
four things they think about
tightness baldness what did you think it
was
like things that surprised them about
the vagina how
much your stretches out holy crap
oh my god they're like whitney
no no no ben have you seen have you swam
summer's still lost in there we have to
go find out there is a common
misconception that women's vaginas can
like stretch if they like date a guy
with a big dick her vagina's gonna be
like
bigger no the average vagina depth is
seven inches
i want to be a neonatal surgeon so bad
benton was almost a neonatal surgeon
well you work with me now so
similar you deal with baby childish
naked people in bathtubs a lot
okay let's hear it okay so the four
things that guys like think about when
they
they're basically the checklist for a
great vagina okay okay now i understand
the game
bald tiny
like wet squirter
i do not squirt so uh fuck all y'all
hydrated bitches out there
and is a butthole
what i mean they'd rather go for your
butthole
oh it's um lasered
tightness wetness
and temperature girls vaginas
um are different some of them are a lot
hotter
mine's apparently very hot like a
jacuzzi because this because they're
like this
when you get into a hot does it explain
i have to worry about the temperature of
my vagina
you don't have to worry about it because
it just is that way or not it's your
it's your body
so he and then the way it's explained to
me is like so like you want the guys
you want it to be hotter because it's
like if you go into it like a hot like a
pool you want to if it's room
temperature you're like okay but if you
go into something that's hot
it feels really good
hotter is better yeah because yeah it
feels like it's hotter
it's like it's like the way it's
described to me it's like a hot pocket
like you don't want to put you he puts
his dick into something that's like
room temp or his his dick temp his dick
it's like okay but it's like warm and
hot but i don't wanna
i don't wanna guys wait hold on
temperature's a thing right
what you're saying sounds right
i would never want i don't think about
the temperature of dicks
do you i know because i think they're
inserting it so it's different but i
guess i've never had a cold
wouldn't that be something wait wait my
vagina
is not particularly like warm and
welcoming
i don't think i think it's it's lukewarm
uh and uh kind of um
harsh conditions not particularly
welcoming emotionally or otherwise
okay yeah so it's like it's like
it's like parts of canada yeah like it
is like winnipeg
is like the winnipeg of vaginas yeah i
don't know i mean there's mine's like
turks and caico
you know i bet i actually bet are you
fully lasered
fully lasered like pretty much from
armpits down
me too yeah i don't know why more
girlfriends don't do in fact after i
told my girlfriend
my best friend this story yeah she went
the next day started lasering everything
off i
but i got laser before they came up with
the new one that didn't hurt i did the
one that was little flames like zinc
yeah i did that when you had to do the
um back you had to
they gave you this the numbing cream you
took you put on the night before i
remember the saran wrap on top
i remember and you come to the doctor's
office with your vagina like saran
wrapped
and um yeah and it still really hurt now
but then
i had to do like i only did a certain
amount of rounds because it was so
painful so painful but then
i went and now they have like the really
good one where they do the cool blast
that's right that's right
and it's amazing they now see we are old
enough to remember when you got laser
and it was just fire they would just
set your vagina on fire and now they
have they just invented this little
thing it's like cold hot cold hot and
you can barely feel it i'm just gonna
say this
i suggest lasering for girls not for the
guys it's just it's just nice it's just
nice you don't have to deal with like
ingrown hair
issues you don't ever have it's just
nice like my like my leg hair it's just
nice me too i just love it i still don't
get hairs on my
toes and i didn't think to get my toes
laser you didn't no it
annoys me because then i have to shave
my stupid toes well go get a little
like a little shot it feels still a
little it feels stupid to go to just
like can i get yeah
they'd be like okay they'd get it they'd
be like yeah like fair enough
yeah are they right now i do get
probably
i get like hairs around my ankles and
you do have to do spot treatment
you know like they go in they go get a
couple spots no i think i shaved them
already see that's a cut from shaving my
toe oh when i see them i see the hair
stupid
did you know what i mean yeah there's
something isn't that stupid and guys are
into sucking toes i'm not into that shit
get the fuck away from my feet i don't
like feeling self-conscious
even if your fetish is your fetish i've
only had like a couple guys do that
i'm good well it's also like weird
because you're just supposed to be like
you're supposed to be like am i supposed
to be do i have to like be do i have to
participate and act like i
will do i have to be part of this like
i'm gonna i'm ticklish i'm gonna kick
you in the mouth
dude i can't i like i'm too ticklish
and there's no way i don't like being
tickled but that didn't stick away it
just felt like
it just feels like you know what it is i
don't know i've lost respect for you
i just what do you why are you that's i
wouldn't go i don't go that far i you're
degrading yourself why are you licking
my feet they're fucking
gross but they might not be doing it to
degrade themselves they may be doing it
because they just there's something
about
i don't i mean i can't it might i do not
have good i do not have like sexy you
probably have sex
i'm looking at them you have gorgeous
feet i would put your feet in my mouth
at this point they're unbelievable well
they're lasered i don't like any kind of
guy degrading themselves in bed i'm very
beta
in bed i i just i'm not do you do role
play or anything like that
nope i don't actually get on my date you
don't make any noise she means better
like the fish she'll find herself
a chance to be alone i want to be alone
do you make any do you
do you like to go down on guys yes but i
don't i'm not a super big fan of guys
going down on me
because most of them aren't very good at
it that's right and i and i don't want
to be a showrunner on my nights off
i mean uh there's a lot of pretending
mm-hmm like i've actually thought about
this so many times about
swear to god i'm like i regret every
time i have fake moaned because these
guys are out there feeling so
fucking confident i have this one in
particular that
was just the worst
the worst at just having sex
in fact he went down on me twice during
the years we were together
and i asked him once and said why don't
you ever go down but by the way i don't
want you to
um but i'm just wondering why because i
feel like most guys i can't get out of
my vagina and i'm like you have to fake
it all the time
so he was like because it's so fucking
warm
it is he said he's like well i just
haven't had a lot of you know
experience doing it and i was like oh
and that's when i was also like um he
may
like benton instead you know it might be
his kind of game and stuff
right right right right but also
the it was like every every time we had
sex every time
dark spooning from behind every time
dark emotionally dark or it was just
dark well it was a dark relationship
but it also lights up like lights out
lights out it was like spooning from
behind
so it's like you don't have to see my
face you have to see that as a girl oh
no yeah and i didn't put all these
pieces together until later
been there and then you're like but i
mean first of all i got evidence about
something
and then i put the other pieces together
i was like oh that's what all that
that's what that
was there's a i mean look i have
dated guys that are gay straight up that
you knew again that's my demo didn't
know what the time didn't did they know
yes i think i i think they
well this one in particular i think had
like repressed it and just was like
disassociating in some way
and it was the only guy i've ever dated
who was like adamantly would not have
sex with me on my period
and it was like so weird that was like
how
it and i remember the time like being
shamed for it
that's the lip balm you got me bent him
ah linnaeus it's the best because it's
actually lip mask oh good yeah
my hands know what they're doing i have
kept olivia here so long her lips are
drying up
nothing not the ones down low i know
those are set i think
everybody you guys are you guys happy
here you guys want to go home to your
loved ones
because i'm fine here she is my loved
one we're doing this forever i'm moving
in
so we basically like i remember calling
a friend of mine and
like i was like embarrassed and like
ashamed and he had actually shamed me
into believing like i was like grow it
was just this
and i didn't realize too late i was like
oh no you just are not into women
oh yeah like it's just a little blood
doesn't which is embarrassing
it is a hassle it is pretty gay to be in
love with women
i mean it's like no it's embarrassing to
like men
i i my girlfriend i told her like how
many years
ago goes with how many years ago this
was but
my um i told my girlfriend i was like
well you know
he wants to like have sex on my period
and she's like i think that's so fucking
hot i was like
why she's like because he doesn't mean
he's not grossed out by things and blah
blah blah blah blah blah
okay and then since then it'd been like
a like i don't
i'm not i'm not that i'm not somebody
that's going will he i wasn't doing what
you were doing like why is he
i don't think about it i'm always like
yeah some people whatever but
um the guys that do which is pretty much
a lot of guys
almost all guys i'm always like oh i
have just because you put that in my
head like that's like i get a little bit
more respect for him
yeah in that way yeah i think it's all
but i don't know if i was a guy i'd want
to have
sex in someone's period but i guess you
know i don't ever have to think about
that
that studio's head said grow up
grow fuck up everybody um
okay i'm gonna ask you a couple other
questions i know i have to let you go at
some point i'm being very selfish
i'm okay and i think i'm kind of we're
just gonna because i know that you can
like this is your it's an unedited thing
yeah i wanna i really am interesting to
see like interested to see how like how
long this can go oh we can do what's the
longest we did i think dave girl was
almost three or four hours
four hours right with not dave grohl but
the longest and you sedaris
that wasn't cat was four hours right pat
dennings was four hours
we did two and then cheated too i think
we also forgot we were
podcasting and we just started hitting
then you just put out the whole thing
like that
i do like a long podcast though if it's
people that that's interesting
and i'm like oh it's only this i don't
i'm like i want it to keep going it's a
road trip you come back to it yeah
i want to talk to you about red flags
because on this
podcast we always talk about red flags
what are some red flags for you
if you're um uh in relationships
friendships also i think is important i
think we have to be careful
with for me like for example one that i
was thinking about this week of
a red flag is a lot of time we think
about like you know oh
they act like this or they do this or
they've been married this many times or
whatever you think
i'm learning that for me my red flags
have to do with the way i feel around
the person
what side of me do they bring out like
if i meet somebody and i instinctively
start performing or trying to be too
funny or trying to take care of them
that's a red flag for me because
whatever's going on with them
is triggering some old child i'm
recreating some childhood circumstances
with them
where i feel the need to be like
unctuous and caretaking and
like walk on eggshells with them and
that's and i just i don't have to know
why but i just have to i know me walking
in eggshells
no that's so real because when i first
met you do you remember this we were in
the green room
and i was just sitting there like
waiting and you went i love that you
don't want to talk to me
yeah to be in silence with somebody for
for benton i mean that's part of the
reason we are so close is
he instantly and sometimes i get
insecure and he'll just walk in and not
say anything i'm like why aren't you
saying good morning and i'll just get
into like an insecure spiral with him
right well you're doing yoga on the
phone
i didn't want to interrupt but it is to
be able to be secure enough
with yourself and the other person to be
able to just sit in silence and just
like not make like bullshit small talk
is so valuable to me that's to me just
like so authentic yeah
so my um it's hard to say like it's
interesting that's a great
like i think a red uh it can be as small
as like
well a red flag in a relationship if if
you're if the guy doesn't love his
mother or a mother figure
great great don't never date a guy
who doesn't love his mother or a mother
figure great
like because he will not love you um i
love red flags um
uh people that can't be alone
who call everybody their best friend is
a red flag for me people who are really
attached to
a fight about something but not actually
fixing a problem yes people that want to
be in the problem and not in the
solution
which most and this is a lot of like
friendships people
it's taken me a long time to realize
that
a lot of people are comfortable in
drama are comfortable in dysfunctional
situations
and when we do work on ourselves that
doesn't mean everyone around us is are
doing
the same congruent work a lot of people
want to be in adrenaline they want to be
in drama it makes them feel important
they want a people please they want to
rescue someone they want to clean up a
mess that's their definition of life
right now with all the social movements
happening a lot of people are more
excited to
fight online than to actually solve the
problem yeah for sure but i just it's
it's in a lot of
friendships when i meet a new potential
friend and they're like i'm in this
relationship and he does this
and i'm like this is going to be
exhausting right
you want to be in something
dysfunctional you don't want to actually
solve it you don't actually leave you
want to stay in it
i've been there i know what that is you
don't actually leave until you're ready
but i'm not going to be able to be a
good friend to you
by just enabling this and listening to
it and you know i'm going to end up
judging you and like
it's just not a good match we're in
different places for the friends
for the friend you know um
i love red flags but it's like
interesting like hearing you guys
hearing your red flags like these are
like i'm like because i i love
seeing them i have i have a i've had a
bad habit of
um like in my in my past like seeing red
flags in relationships and just
continuing to walk i can i'm like oh
that's a fire
i can contort a red flag i can like
paint a red flag white
i can go this i can see a red flag and
say okay this person hates their mom
and i can turn it into you need to be
more forgiving
and more compassionate and this person
is going to make you better and this
person is a trauma survivor and
you're going to heal the rift with his
mom you're going to fix his relationship
with his mom
and i will mother micromanage and martyr
and think i need to repair their
relationship instead of just going no
just turn around
make a u-turn get the fuck out of here
mine is is that
i i think to myself you know what i fuck
up and i mess up yep
and you know what i'd like somebody to
give me another shot which is true and
that's yeah healthy attitude but the
thing is i find with people is like
especially with
the guys in the past where they mess up
and i forgive them too fast
because i because i go through them like
okay and like they haven't really
learned their lesson
enough they're kind of like this reset
where they kind of would go back
um uh i there's a girlfriend that i
i liked um and she's in her business and
i um we finally had dinner and hanging
out at her house and then she was like
telling me about her life like really
got
really into it which is totally cool i
like getting right into things but then
she says to me
because of things that happened to me
when i was younger like i'm just such a
big flirt like i flirt with
everyone like i just can't help it like
all my friends like my friends are used
to it so i flirt with their husbands and
their boyfriends and just it's just like
how i am i just kind of
i just you know i feel like i get you
know i get validated by my sexuality and
it's nothing
like not to worry about but like it's
just something that i do but like i
would never act on it and i was just
like
i never hung out with that girl again
off after
that i'll tell you guys who she is but i
was just like it was just like i was
like
people you know people who that's a red
flag people who admit
because you know there's a there's a
great um philosopher francois de los
trava called
he says um and i said that fast i'm not
sure if i pronounced it right
like ran through that running smoking
thing because i'm pretty sure i
butchered it
um but uh he's like we often admit to
our small faults
to convince others we have no bigger
ones so if somebody right off the bat is
gonna be like
so um i flirt with your boyfriend or
husband because i'm just insecure about
myself
that's all i do that's my only thing i'm
like you know so i had a baby with your
boyfriend
yeah someone who's always like i just
tell it how it is i'm always telling you
no yeah that's somebody
tricking you into thinking that they are
um
uh self-aware and safe yeah like i'm
acknowledging this one flaw so i'm so
forthcoming and i have no secrets
because if i told you that one little
secret
why would i lie about anything else
right you know it's so manipulative yeah
you're like i'm you're telling me that
one little one because you've got
bigger ones and also fix it
yeah also fucking fix it how about that
the person who's just like this is how
my childhood was so i'm fixed like this
forever that's not how neurology works
at all
and so if i do fuck up it's your fault
because i told you
right so now the ball's in your court
and now i'm the one that admitted it
so if i do it it's now your fault
because i told you it was going to
happen
yeah now you're dumb for letting me do
this i told you this is just who i
am i'm authentic this is just how i am
bye
fucking bad fucking people who
like use their childhood at in their 40s
as a scapegoat to their shitty behavior
because their therapy for that is also a
red flag oh yeah someone mentions that
they go to therapy like four or five
times in a conversation yeah yeah yeah
what what are you doing yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean it's also using
uh yeah fake i also think just i had a
friend who would always be like well i
can do this because my therapist says i
need my there and i'm like okay well i'm
not your therapist yeah yeah yeah yeah
like a normal person
yeah yeah i think that there there's a
lot of um
i'm going to admit all my flaws so now
it's your fault if i hurt you
yeah that's exactly what it is you know
what i mean like i already showed you
yeah i showed you i told you everything
that's bad about me now you're
um you're sick for moving forward with
me
or it's your fault now and then i feel
like i am like yeah why didn't i run
yeah why the fuck because i mean i think
there's also something like really
beguiling and disarming about someone
who admits all their flaws there's
something
you know and as you were talking about
that i realized a big red flag for me is
over
sharing too much too soon and trauma
bonding
so if you're if you're on a first date i
should not know
about all your abuse as a child i should
not know this stuff like i've got a lot
of that stuff too and it's taken me a
long time to realize i don't need to
lead with that because what i'm trying
to subconsciously do
is avoid abandonment by getting you to
pity me somehow so i'm going to
tell you all the horrible things that
ever happened to me so you feel sorry
for me because i don't think i'm enough
unless i'm damaged or broken i think
that's what's interesting about me
because i'm insecure about this
conversation so i'm going to try to be
interesting by saying all the awful
things that happen to me
and then i'm going to overexpose myself
so i feel even worse if you don't want
to keep seeing me i'm now
gonna feel like disgusting and super
rejected i'm setting myself up for an
even bigger disappointment
but it's like subconsciously my way of
trying to sink my
hooks into you so that you won't abandon
me by over
sharing you know and i've been in so
many relationships where
we just overshared way too much
entrenched in the beginning
conflated love and pity trauma bonded
well you're creating a false sense of
intimacy that's right you're like if you
know all of this about me now we're
really close that's right
and the only thing that creates
closeness is just time that's right
like time and then trust builds into
that you know but it's
yeah you know what i was thinking this
is not a red flag but
um but something within me that's
probably red flag for somebody else yeah
but i was like like i wish i was more
interesting like i wish i had more you
talk about like
you're like want to say all this stuff
about your childhood and maybe really
interesting i'm like
i don't like like i don't know art i
really don't
like you you know what francois francois
de love you know very sponsored
uh i know how to say like um oh i love
the use of negative space
me too i know how to do this oh i love
how they collapse three dimensions into
two
i love the use of negative space and i
just use that every place i go
oh my god i love the use of negative
space here and they look at me i'm like
i know
oh my god i love i don't the use of
negative space i'm not a big art person
but a guy took me
to mocha is that the
museum of modern contemporary art
downtown in l.a
and i only know art based on how
expensive it is based
same with wine i only know if wine is
good based on how pretty the label is
that i'm trash period yeah and we went
to mocha
and at every painting i asked the
security guard i was like how much is
this oh my god
and they're like they're like priceless
it's at the mocha
they're like we don't know i haven't
said can we google how much this costs
like and then they're like it's 80
million dollars i'm like oh this must be
good
i just don't i don't underst i remember
being
at i remember it you know i grew up in
oklahoma and i'm
not i grew up in japan but went to
school in oklahoma
and i remember doing college went down
to dallas to whatever their big museum
is there that's how
non-artsy i am i don't know what it is
and i remember seeing this
painting it was just red my best friend
in college she's an architect major and
she loves art
um she's really smart she's one of those
people that says negative space but
knows what he's known about
but there's actually negative space i
i'm a devil's advocate i like positive
space
yeah i'm looking at a where's waldo and
i'm like i love the use of negative
space
um and she goes um so i'm looking at it
and i'm like see i don't get this yeah
like
i can do this i can do this
and i can sit outside this motherfucking
museum and be like mine are just 25
grand to pop
y'all if you want this that's 80 million
in there i love that as soon as you went
to dallas you said yeah
no it comes out of me and she was like
no the reason why it's so difficult and
why this is such a piece of art is
because
you know to do this there's no paint
strokes there's no it's like it's
it's all the symmetry and it's just
evenly painted he just did the whole
thing and i was like still like
yeah i don't see i think that's actually
more interesting that i don't know yeah
that you're just kind of like
i don't like it true it's refreshing
it's refreshing but after a while like
that's my that's my thing and every
dinner i think it'd be like
pick you guys i don't want that thing
and they're gonna be like okay
olivia they're gonna be like oh do you
guys see the new um
you know david mayment play and i'm like
i mean as an actress i'm like i don't
really
i'm just like oh i'm like who's mammoth
i gotta only by the way don't know a
mammoth i mean i'm an actor
who like isn't that artsy but i really
fucking
try to pretend you know like um david
harbor we were in the newsroom together
so we're friends and yeah back in the
day i remember he
i was like he was like oh they're doing
this uh play like a shakespeare in the
park or whatever and i was like oh we
should go see it he's like yeah you want
to let's go
i was like cool i was like so um this
play i heard it's on at this time do you
want to go he's like great we'll meet
you there
he's like you got it you're good i'm
like yeah yeah i'll meet you there we
get there and he was like
so he's like you get the tickets i was
like oh no i thought we'd just get them
here and he's like olivia
i was like what he's like it's
shakespeare in the park and it's this
play with these people and i was like
those people are the people want to come
see them and he was like
yeah and it's this play and i'm like and
that's a big play huh and he was like
he's like and there's no more tickets
because
he's like hold on so because he's
because he's very artsy yeah
he knows the whole world he's like hold
on he goes around he gets sneaks us in
they put us in the back and i was like
oh and that was a time when i felt like
oh i'm real i'm a dumb dumb but here's
no no no i'm also
i think the most interesting people are
the ones that are able to say like
i get why that was good 300 years ago
but
we since have more interesting shit but
see i can't find the since interesting
shit though either i'm with you i ca
i can't the old one or the new one oh
yeah that's
shakespeare is fucking boring it's
it wasn't boring when it was the only
shit to watch
i get yeah it was interesting back then
it's not that fucking interesting i've
been to shakespeare in the park
there's like bugs but what's interesting
ufc that is
shakespeare talk about it riveting
people just like beating the shit out of
each other the edge of my
seat there's blood there's broken bones
i mean yeah i'm also like i i think it's
just to be able to like
it even there sorry not to even then i
love usc and even then
i can't hold a conversation about how
in-depth it is and maybe it's just
because i can't
really get into anything for too long to
i feel like i can't hold a con i mean i
can hold a conversation about like the
shit that i've gotta
i've been i put into fires yeah but like
i really don't think i can
really like hold a really long
conversation
why should you have to yeah you don't
have to you're why yeah you're you i
mean that's the other thing is that i
feel like there's this
this half the time people can quote hold
a conversation
they're being full of shit anyway like
like when i
i was talking to someone about about
woody allen the other day because i
have never liked woody allen movies i
don't think they're fucking funny
i've never thought they were good even
before the shit came out about him i
didn't think his stand-up was funny
i've always been in fights about this i
do not think men being weak and scared
is funny i think it's fun he's a fucking
pussy i've never
like you know dan keaton is amazing in
annie hall he's
brilliant at casting and getting great
performers i've never
thought any and and if you love new york
it's all a love letter in new york i get
it
but i've never and i was like fighting
with someone about this and they're like
but it's so big and i was like do you
really believe this are you just saying
this
because you think you're supposed to
condition and you heard it it sounds
good it sounds good
yeah like i think we're all just like so
full of shit
you know and i think it's important when
you're able to go like do i really
believe that or am i just like trying to
fit in or trying to make people like me
are trying to seem smart to me the most
interesting people are the people like
i don't get that i just i don't get it
it doesn't do anything for me you've
just met your most interesting i was
gonna say i love you
i don't know i remember with like like
david lynch i did that
i remember running around being like
it's so genius and then i'm talking to
other people because i went
you know i minored in film we're like
this is so genius and then i remember
being like
why is it genius like can someone just
explain it to me and everyone was like
wait oh no
it's like like citizen ruth is fucking
genius and blue velvet is is
i now understand yeah but at the time i
was just like are we all so insecure
that we're pretending like
i kind of want to put out um like i
think david lynch should just put out a
total nonsense movie and just watch
critics say it's the most brilliant
thing ever
just because everyone's so afraid to say
they don't understand something
yeah okay taking another break
from our lovely conversation with olivia
munn what a dream
what a dream boat she is icon legends i
love on this podcast that we talk about
therapy
people really enjoy it and i appreciate
that people let me be so open and
authentic and vulnerable about the fact
that i
need help good help
better help frankly better help heard of
it heard of it
love it we do bet we love better help
because here at good for you we don't
pretend to be okay
we are broken we are a
shattered uh mere suggestion of a person
we are hanging by a thread and we admit
that what would you talk to a therapist
about
i i mean i'm perfect i was just
i think right now i've been
lonely what if i started crying in the
better health ad
no i've just it's it's lonely and i
think also the amount of anger that i'm
seeing
around people because there's a lot of
uncertainty we don't know if schools are
going to open we don't know
when we're going to be able to get back
to normal and i'm seeing a lot of like
anger and pain come up and when i see
people in the grocery store yell at each
other at masks
i want to interfere but i know i can't i
have to mind my business
yours are different than mine what are
yours what are you going to do
you know i would like to talk to theirs
about why i cry every time i listen to a
kelly clarkson song
even the empowering ones or why i'm
still torn up about the ending of a walk
to remember her name should be kelly
catharsis that's a good one we love that
we love better help there's a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be locally available in many areas
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help this is professional
counseling done
securely online i also just wrote better
help into a script
yeah you did i did i did script there's
a whole script
that i'm working on and better help is
in it betterhelp
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches they make it easy
and free to change
counselors it's so great because you can
just do it in the privacy
the comfort of your own home you don't
have to drive to a therapist office and
find parking and feed the meter and then
you can't find a quarter and then the
meter runs out and then you just
got a ticket for going to therapy and
then you're like to the universe you're
like i guess you don't want me to go to
therapy and then you stay crazy
better help solves all of that rigmarole
started communicating in under 48 hours
i can't even get you to text me back in
that amount of time that's correct why
don't you talk to your better help
counselor about that because i feel some
resentment coming at me
betterhelp.com whitney that's better
h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people
that's awesome taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp that they're
recruiting additional counselors in
all 50 states special offer to good for
you listeners
where you get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney uh
we love thrive you are i'm obsessed i'm
obsessed
i love thrive too but no one loves
thrive as much as you yeah
because i'm a weirdo i i'm a weirdo
with the stuff that i put in my body
yeah we ordered
crazy we order sunflower seeds cheese
doodles grape seed oil wine
lavender it looks like we're witches
alcoholic witches with a child
but this thrive what i love about this
company is they deliver
organic sustainable groceries right to
your door when i send men to get
groceries he comes back with
nothing i want the grocery store is an
adventure for me okay you
you never get me what i asked for this
is this company does
uh it is true when i ask him to go
get me um vegetables he'll come back
with these
no he kept he'll go back with his like
nasty like passive aggressive sliced
mushrooms i'm like what are you what am
i going to do with these
remember you'll come back with just like
celery i'm like i don't want any of this
like
so i love thrive because you can
essentially go in
and um say the kind of stuff that you
like and what your dietary restrictions
are and then they only show you products
that are
what you like yeah because i hate it
when you buy something you're like oh
god i can't eat this it has darian or i
can't you know
when it's already gotten home and you
eat it anyway because you have no
self-control and then it's just you're
full of shame and it's a whole
nightmare this is where i get that i
discovered that avocado oil
i am now obsessed with cooking with
avocado oil
the little almond coffees that i have
you're obsessed with
i i drink them all day the grape seed
oil i put on my face i even get from
here everybody asks me where i get my
my luminous glow it's from the grape
seed oil that i get on thrive
and the hundred cheese puffs you eat i
do eat lots of organic cheese puffs it's
like it's
like i have a two year old i just put
them in a ziplock bag and i put them in
your purse and set you off to work
as a member uh you'll also save 25 to 50
percent off traditional retail prices
which is amazing i cannot stand it when
kale chips are like 12
carbon neutral shipping is free on
orders over 49
that's awesome thrive market tailors to
70 different diets and values whether
you're paleo keto
plant-based delivering the highest
quality organic and sustainable
essentials from groceries healthy snacks
meat
seafood clean wines love it non-toxic
cleaning
bath and body everything you need is
here the savings i get on my favorite
clean organic products are awesome
i just also feel good about helping to
support communities in need
in addition to membership matching
thrive market raised over 750 000
to date through their covid 19 relief
fund which is incredible awesome
go to thrivemarket.com good for you join
today and you'll get a free gift of your
choosing
up to 22 dollars in value thrive
t-h-r-i-v-e
market dot com slash good for you start
your risk-free membership and get a free
gift
today thrive market dot com slash good
for you
once you've made a decision that
something or someone is amazing
yeah it's really that's hard for them to
fall
yeah so it's like you want to keep you
want to support them because it's like
not them you can't you know it's real
that's
that's why people you know that's why
some people are able to you know skirt
around some things because people
don't want them to fall yeah it takes a
lot i mean same thing with like um
in relationships i was just today my
girlfriend was telling me about
a friend of hers who caught her
boyfriend cheating and all that and he
said he wasn't and she's still staying
with him
and i said well she's like she just
wants to believe i said well what she
what she's what when what she's hearing
is i'm leaving you
and not um like i cheat on you
so what she wants to hear instead of him
saying i didn't cheat on you i can't
believe that she believes him because
he she knows she caught him she saw him
with the girl
like yeah but what she's not she's
hearing is i didn't cheat on you she's
not hearing that she's what she's
hearing is i'm not going to leave you
because for whatever reason in her head
she he needs to be this person for her
right now it's too much
and i said you gotta she's like what
should i do as a friend i said you gotta
let her write it out
because she's not emotionally able to
take the idea of him leaving her
that's right and so you got a letter
even i've told a friend that
her person was cheating on her too soon
ruined our friendship
oh i thought i was like being the big
hero coming in
telling her the truth i would want to
know and it was like destroyed our
friendship
i wish i would always want to know right
i'm i'm the girl
tell me everything even if i'm crying
afterwards remember like you have to
tell me i'll be so much more upset
later i'm like i just i like to know
like the truth that's what you it's like
it's taken me so long as an adult to
realize you just have to find
your tribe of people that think like you
because if you're in friendships where
like
you're the type of person that wants to
know and they're the type of person
that's like doesn't want to
it's just like it's not sustainable i
have a friend
who i like well i have friends who like
well one friend
well she'll ask me something and i'll
literally say like do you want to hear
the truth or do you want
oh and she'll and she'll because she
knows me so well i'm like do you wanna
hear
what i really think or do you want me to
just tell you
something that will make you feel good
and she goes sometimes she'll be like
just tell me something makes me feel
yeah yeah like okay great
but like she's also a friend that's like
if these jeans don't look good on her
she doesn't want to know she'll get
annoyed with you but with me i'm like
you tell me if it makes my ass look flat
or makes my ass look weird or whatever
like tell me that those pockets are like
what what are people doing with pockets
now like it's very specific like yeah
so like i want to oh if i came over here
and i thought i looked great and you're
like olivia
don't wear those jeans again i'd be like
thank you
you look too good and it's hurting my
feelings no well
i'd always want to know that i do when
um friends of mine call me to talk about
relationships it's taken me
37 years to figure out but i go do you
want to talk about the problem or do you
want to solve the problem
and most of the time it's like oh i just
want to talk about it it's like great at
least i know what gear to be in
i'm listening do you want me to listen
and just fucking bitch with you
or do you actually want to work towards
a solution i need to know so that i
don't end up
codependence doesn't start breeding
resentment where i'm like i was on the
phone with you trying to solve this
i don't want to fuck up my friendship i
don't know i am
one time i was with my girlfriends like
um some for my
three of my closest girlfriends and i
said um i was looking around i said you
know what
like what they each bring i go my my oh
my one friend um
kara she's like kind of like my resident
guy she thinks like a guy
she operates so if you ever like what
was he thinking or what should i do
she's like that's
she's the one who can help you my
girlfriend brooke she's like always down
to do whatever like you know if you know
i always want to sing at home and eat
ice cream okay let's do that let's go
out to a bar okay let's do that like
she's always cool
um my other girlfriend jessica she's got
ocd like me and we can just sit at home
and then we can kind of just like
you know do nothing and kind of get your
ocd or she can help me clean up
everything yeah so she's
so i'm like i see what i i see what you
guys each bring to my life
but like what do i bring to yours like
i'm like what what friend am i
like oh my yeah who am i what am i
bringing because i see how they're
staying and
um my friend brook goes whenever
anything happens to any of us the first
thing you ask is
what do you want and i was like oh she's
like so if
her boyfriend break up i don't judge i'm
not i'm just go what do you want you
want to get him back even if i think
he's an asshole
or do you want to make him suffer or
what what do you want
even though i don't agree with it as
long as it's legal i will help you get
there you want to go drive by
we want to hack into his shit like let's
figure this out we want to go find that
girl
what do you want you want to call his
mom let's call his mom what do you want
that's me and i like and i'm not telling
you i'm not telling you what to want i'm
going to help you get whatever it is
yeah and then later on we'll deal with
like the you know
ethics of it right now we don't have
time for ethics what do you want
because like you know that's like a
thing i was like that means okay that's
that made me feel good i'm like okay now
i know
i love that friend um now the most
important question of the podcast
what do you do to your skin i see
shawnee darden
um do you know shawnee just a fan didn't
we try to get an appointment with
shawnee darden yes
no dice um during the difference yeah it
happened
right whenever we were getting the
emails back so you dropped the ball
no i didn't drop the ball the email said
you can't come in that's what i'm saying
my vagina was too far back she wouldn't
accept me
i also do ulthera i did ulthera
it's why don't i look like you oh my god
oh look my
i'm hoping i need to do it more on my
neck ulthera is a laser
that hurts like oh fuck but
it's one of the most painful things ever
oh truly truly of it if you find the
right per so the
what ulthera does is it it's a laser
that it goes deep into the
bottom of your skin and like where like
if they were to do a facelift somebody
explain this to me if they do a facelift
they open up your skin and then they
cauterize underneath which then creates
collagen which then like fills it up
and so this laser is just on the it's
topical so it's on the outside
so that laser goes as far down as like
if they were doing a facelift right
so it goes that far down but in order to
get that same effect they have to be in
the same spot
50 times like 50 spots like zap you that
many times
and it it's literally torture it it it's
like something holds a hot iron
that's in your face that's right and it
um has to damage
the bottom leave your skin so much that
it starts to produce more collagen
like it's a trauma to your face yeah i
did it
two or three times over like maybe like
three years or something
and i took two vicodin
i had to smoke weed because i was
getting like physically violent with the
person that was doing it
and then the thing is like this so when
they're doing it you can't say stop
because they have to keep doing it oh
until because
they need to create that burn down there
you can't stop and go so that's why
you have to go 50 if it says 50 times
right there you got to hold on now
if you have the wrong person so it's
interesting because um i was looking at
the machine i had somebody show me once
and like playing video games like i i
was able to see like oh it's kind of
like a video game i'm like you have to
go i tell the person myself
because you have your nerves that come
through and you see on the screen
there's like this black
line and there's a white line and you
can see where the nerve comes through
and they just have to find it in this
right space where the nerve isn't there
and then once you
see it i'm like now you now go now go
now go so i go
i will guide them so that's why it hurts
so much because you have the woman
you're just going over your face
and just doing it over and over but your
your your face is like moving around and
and your nerves are jumping because it's
like you know yeah
so i watched the screen and be like go
here stop stop stop stop like
whack-a-mole
yeah it is it's like a little video game
you got to go it's okay now it's right
there but it is
it was a huge help yeah but the topical
lasers a lot of people asked me about
this because my face is so fucking shiny
the topical lasers i found thin my skin
they say did you ever do um a flaxsell
broccoli well i never thought well no
the thing if you ever do people do
um like acid peels and things like that
yeah because when you do too many peels
on your skin or even just one
you're um you actually strip your pores
off so your oil doesn't have anywhere to
go and
underneath that's why people's skin
looks too shiny and that's why this oil
stays on top
you have to be really careful too many
times of like stripping your skin off
your
the top because that's why you see these
older women and they all look shiny and
then the thing is they think they look
young but
just everybody ends up looking old
because they all look that it's like a
super old lizard yeah you have to be
really careful about how much you strip
your skin and when you do these topical
lasers like the
what's it called um fraxel fracture
there's another one um
uh laser bright some shit it takes the
hair off your face
and that makes your face shinier as well
why do you
it's like takes off the top what is it
called um laser out
of the laser i've done it it's like to
get off sun spots and stuff like that i
would always do it
photo photo facial is this real
photo facial it was in a mini mall like
photosynthesis in resida
it was it's whatever the topical thing
that takes off the dead skin cells on
top yeah i've done uh bbl broadband
light treatment
which is spot treatment on my sunspots
that was a huge difference that's good
because i actually since covid i haven't
done it in like and i can tell like i've
you know been out in the sun more or
whatever but like that brightens up your
face a lot more than just doing your
whole fucking face
your skin is wild really so good oh my
god thank you so much
so so beautiful do you have any like
major products you love besides
shani but she sells products yeah she
starts selling products yeah
um i i've been kind of obsessed with the
like honest beauty oil and then this uh
the other skincare line called mara and
she's got a lot of really interesting
like creams and bombs
um that korean lip thing yes
yes benton got this for me i have it
beside my bed and i kind of make my own
body lotions like with kind of like
coconut oil
and like different stuff like that nice
um just because
not only during pandemic because i was
bored because i'm looking at people like
full amish oh my god people are doing so
much on instagram and i was like
it's sad i mean it's hard to watch it is
hard to watch it's hard to watch frankly
it's really can i tell you something and
and i know i have to let you go
i must command you you say that because
you need me i don't
know but i know you keep saying that i
keep saying i'm cool and i feel like you
really want to leave
no i'm having so much fun and i'm just
codependently worried that i'm like
like bothering you but it's a pandemic
so where the fuck are you going to go
yeah i've got nowhere to go i'm so
excited um you're not going to an art
museum you don't care yeah
no i'm going to the moca they have a
great use of negative space
they have a sale on the painting on the
negative space your
social media is one of the few that
doesn't
bother me really yeah tell me more
because
i'm like that's an anxiety there's a lot
of people on social media and i don't
know if it's just because the pandemic
and people are being removed from their
ability their
their isms and their drugs people are
not getting attention the way they
normally do people are getting desperate
for attention especially performers
they're not able to go on stage they're
not able to act or do whatever the thing
is that gets them their
fill of you know ego boost
i've i've definitely there's i've had to
mute a lot of people that i love
in the last couple months because of the
lives and the
i'm all of a sudden a chef and i'm all
of a sudden you know it's just
i i always am like she nails it really
that makes me feel so good
i get anxiety with the glam shots
because but you are fucking fuck
you man you're adorable about it she
posts like the
ones that aren't this stupid like water
in a cave and you're like oh what is she
doing
but no but she'll have like this
gorgeous glamour shot and then she'll
post like the ones that
where she's like really stupid her eyes
closed or where because most of them are
that
yeah yeah like the ones where she tried
because to get one good photo you take
50 shitty ones
well that makes me feel better that you
appeal that because like i
when i go through the pictures i'm like
i think
i try not i i i try not to be
too impressionable but i
think that social media has
ingrained in me that the dead eye look
is the look
like i'm like so if you look through all
my fucking pictures oh my
where i think that all my look is just
like it's all dead-eyed or like i just
like
i just i just saw a deer your eye
your eyes are negative space yes um it's
just like
i look at them and i'm like oh my god i
can't oh oh i'm looking through it makes
me embarrassed right now because i look
oh yeah i don't think i want to show you
i don't think that's why
you know you guys are instagramming no
no no i'm looking for the pictures i
took today before i came over
i'm not embarrassing i can't i can't
even are you gonna post that
i'll post something but it'll be the
ones that are less like when you see
them
i'll show you an embarrassment but no no
no it's not just one it's
a collective when you look at how many i
did and how like the amount
in the different poses have to deal with
your psylocke sword when you hit that
painting yeah see that was like the
first time i did it i was like
and i tried to do more if i was like you
know what this is the one i'm like i i'm
like i fucked up whatever move on i hurt
the frame of my artwork
i'll show you an embarrassing one oh my
god this is me
in palm springs trying to take like a
chill selfie but so how many so
my thing is this that one's okay but
one's okay
i did three i did three and then i
realized they weren't going
do you have a home in palm springs and i
stopped no this was me visiting tim
dillon a friend of mine
but i i usually give up after two after
three i know there's
we're not getting anywhere okay so my
thing is i'm trying to do the pose here
we go here we go wait wait wait there's
there's oh
here's a grid wait but is that for we
know those aren't your glam ones those
are you like showing something on your
skin i was like showing off my white
eyeliner and i took a lot oh
i take her glam ones that's why benton
handles my social but here's the thing
about
the one they're too close to like hold
on whitney
loves the phone right up in the face no
but you gotta like do this thing
this one this arrow thing will make it
go out a little bit more so if you go
really
say look if you go really close look at
that and then that arrow won't just like
won't make your your everything look
yeah but like this is i was actually
this is you know when you like look at
your phone and you're consumed with
shame because you were trying to take
one photo and you had to take 50 and you
still don't have a good one
oh so well this is better so my problem
is i'm
i'm you know your angle you i think you
you sort of
hold it up a little bit um yeah i do i
there's a there's 7 30 um
p.m i get some good light and it's above
me
i'm not kidding either no but here's the
thing is that i am not an influencer and
i am not a reality star
i am an actor and i try and i'm like
yeah yeah i
i'm so influenced by how they post and
then i'm like
and i'm like what are you doing olivia
and then i'm like i just wanted to look
i'm like i wanted to look like you just
caught me you're an influencer
but like i'm like but no one's caught me
it's a selfie i'm like your arms
i know and i'm just like oop me why i'm
trying to be
cute like i'm like these girls like you
know i like i look at kendall jenners
and she's like
palm springs with my bathing suit and
i'm like me too
you're an influencer whether you want to
be or not but but look i don't know
but if i try to i cannot keep up with
the kardashians
like for real it is so funny when we
take selfies of ourselves and try to
pretend we don't know we're taking them
you guys
most of the time i'll tell you this i'm
going to show you this
but look on my face i'm going to zoom in
on this one you're going to see it
from afar it looks like this oh no all
right it looks like i'm just like from a
pharmacy but if you look at my eyes cute
look at my dead eyes you can see that
right
i'm like this this is what it looks like
over zombie you look like a wax figure
my face my look see how i'm smiling
but my eyes are like please tell me this
worked i guess
please tell me this works do you have
your phone on a self-timer
by the way i do but this one i love that
that's the person i used to see at
parties 15 years ago
oh she's so confident she's sent
together if you came closer to me you
would be like her eyes oh my gosh
and by the way this is most of it is me
going like this like did i do it
most of them are this one of me and the
timers going off and so i'm just like is
this
but i can't post that because it's
really cute though
wait well there was a lot of them then
there was this one then i thought then i
then i thought i'm just going to walk
you through it then i off my then
somebody walked in to the door
and then i saw the the on the self timer
oh that might have been cute
oh something so i'm like hey i thought
maybe i'll do a pointed one
and then i was like oh my god you said
and then i'll be going over here
then i'm like i'm gonna be pointing at
my house and then i thought
you know what i can't do this so now i'm
i came up with my caption i was like i'm
gonna be i'm gonna post a caption says
i'm pointing at nothing
but then they all just came out stupid
because then the joke was not that funny
after
like 20 photos and it's just it's so
demoralizing
it really is but i like that you show
sort of the all the evidence and
emotional detritus involved in taking
one
celebrity selfie that's so glamorous
you show all the weird like awkward ones
that go along with it
most of the time my face looks like this
did that work
i mean is it working it's
horrible just the panic oh the worst is
when you
have to like make yourself laugh for a
picture and try to look like it's a
genuine laugh oh yeah i got those in
here too
hold on you like try to just crack
yourself up so it looks like an organic
laugh and you're just like oh god i hate
myself
well then i'm trying to show the outfit
oh wait here we go hold on this is let
me show you this is probably my most
humiliating one so i did a a partnership
with caulipower pizza
this is the number of photos that benton
had to take of me
oh my god it's because i had to keep
going joy joy you're happy
you look so pretty you do you do her
makeup right no sometimes sometimes i do
but usually usually but it's so pretty i
do this occasionally for fun
but who did this she'll slap it on
that's me but it's
very that's very nice uh what uh like
you were coming today
you didn't add you look like you he's an
ad yeah
no no i just sit around with then i
leave the pizza box out
you know like don't you you know the
thing about people asking you to do ads
it's like
don't you think it's more influential if
they like let you put the the box
upside down and like make it look more
natural they're like no place the box
like this i actually don't do it i have
a
theory about that i know you pass on
everything i know that's the only reason
i get anything is because you fucking
pass i
pass on this cauliflower big vegan
people thank you thank you for passing
so
other other people get crumbs i really
appreciate it but i'm not living in this
you're like
ridiculous like you own topanga canyon i
did you're right
i don't own tabanga can you literally
bought it with vegan pizza i have
yeah with all of the crumbs you've
thrown me i have managed to build a real
estate empire so what were you saying
woman's trash another person canyon
i'm trying to look my phone photos are
all dogs
and videos of you ben oh god this is
pretty embarrassing oh god
you know when you try to do a selfie oh
god this is me and my dog
here's another chunk of selfies i tried
to do
like a burst here's the interesting
thing right
a selfie no longer is just um for why is
your face so shiny that you have a mask
on
like it's like overly shiny right right
this is what my face looks like before i
go to bed
what do you put on it i lube it up in
oil
like snail yeah it's i i put on
grape seed oil i put on this oil that
you're getting in your gift bag called
what are you doing okay don't sweat too
much jesus oil mom has been sending some
nudes in quarantine it might be easy
with the swiping olivia
wait so but but the interesting thing is
when you take those you were taking them
to for yourself or you're taking them to
post
i don't know she will post some this
look how fucking shiny i look i look
bat shit crazy okay here's wait look at
this
i'm covered you've seen this this is the
worst one when i'm like
i'm acting as if i'm taking like i'm in
a photo shoot in my own home
when it clearly is on self-timer like
it's more pathetic because
is that a drawing of the guy from um a
six-fingered man
it is that's amigo montoya a friend drew
that for me
that's amazing yeah weird good eye
thank you i was looking at your butt i
mean and then you scroll down and i
scroll down
there it is okay so this is
it's just so humiliating to go through
your
photo it really is bringing up a lot
this is one i probably will post because
it's just like look like
but i'm like i look this is me it's not
supposed to be gorgeous so
how many oh god you oh sorry i didn't
look at your face actually
it's gorgeous but you look um like
you're having either a seizure or an
orgasm both
what um how many photos does it take to
get like the selfie oh wait wait oh oh
my god
okay so many before benton did one
i had to do this is actually the most
embarrassing thing in my phone
more embarrassing than nudes more
embarrassing than pretty much everything
this is me trying to do the first round
of photos of me
posing with a pizza oh no
oh there there's so many in your fridge
it's as if there's nothing else that you
eat is that part of the ad you know they
tell you all these things that you can't
i had to wear green they said you had to
wear green yeah they preferred it
but to be fair she does eat those pizzas
i really i mean i had them
so i was like i meant as well do you
still have them yeah cauli power
but look at how many photos i took and i
don't think i posted any of them you
know what i like to do
hold on i like this one i can see i'm
gonna hold it we're gonna get the live
action
oh i love that watching her just oh that
was like a oh then the mouth comes open
at this point
oh yeah there it is it's alive but it
goes this and then she's going to uh
sometimes you'll see when you listen to
the picture and if you hold it down
she'll go
you see me at the end of it she'll go
yeah
what if they just let us take what we
really want to take it's just like us
with the cash
i just pizza done um okay
last thing last thing i swear i'm gonna
ask you is do you have any money advice
for people
i always like to ask people money advice
i always say
uh put away 30 of your paycheck because
you don't have it
if you make a hundred dollars you did
not make a hundred dollars she made
seventy dollars right cause you're gonna
have to pay taxes later took me a long
time to figure that out do you have any
like
things you wish you would learn when you
were younger about money
well i think the best piece of advice i
could give about money is it's not
how much you make it's how much you save
people are spending way too much and
we're wanting to buy these
so much you know like you want to keep
up with people i want to have this i
want to it's like
it's not how much you make it's how much
you save you can make a ton
and you can spend it on a lot of crap
you know all that really matters how
much you have in your bank account how
much you can
like you know like take care of yourself
so the reason why i do say no to a lot
of things is because
um i save my money i'm like i'm a big
saver i always have been
and i don't like i don't
need like all these multiple homes yet
yeah
um i just don't see that need right now
and
uh and so i save all my money so that i
i just learned early on or i believed
early on
that if i saved my money i would never
have to take a job
just to pay my bills i want to be able
to have my artistic integrity
and you know that's what my money is
being saved for so that i can make
artistic decisions based on whatever i
want to do not what i have to do
and by the way that means i can take a
risk here and there or i can say no to
things and
i mean the other day i said you know
right before the pandemic i said no to
something like it was a lot of money
but there was just too many variables it
looked really great it was a really
great
project and i loved everything about it
um
but the executive producer who wrote the
first two episodes
that i read were it was amazing he's
amazing but he wasn't going to keep
writing them after that he's going to be
executive producer but there's going to
be somebody else writing after that and
i just
was like i just didn't think that i
could sign up for something that i
didn't know who was going to be writing
after that and so my worst case scenario
was not
this show um bombing um
it was it being moderately successful
and i have to do it for six years yeah
and so then i'm on this show that
i think starts off really great i think
it's really interesting but i just don't
know who would be
who am i signing on yeah or on the third
episode and from then on and then
and then i'd make so much money and i
mean everybody was like i had to head to
the
studio call and be like hey do you know
you're gonna like we're talking you're
like
yeah they're like in a few years you're
gonna be you know here but i think
people don't understand when they say
like you're gonna make all this money
it's like but i'm gonna be working all
that i'm not gonna be spending it i'm
gonna be spending
you know eight months in vancouver from
seven a.m to midnight like
it's just sort of like what about my
time right and i think that
but as an actor i if it was like if it
was the newsroom again with aaron sorkin
and they said olivia for the next
you know 10 months a year you're going
to be doing sloane sabbath with aaron
sorkin
until the day you die i'd sign up mm-hmm
i'd be like that's because i cuz that
was just it fulfilled me so much i loved
it so much
if this show was like it's going to be
this this quality this we promise you
it's with this
this writer this show runner this then i
would have done it
but um like i had to
i was like i don't i don't know like i
might you know
the time is all we have yeah that's i
think that's the
biggest thing about money that i think
the best thing about money is that
it gives us time you know when you have
money you can
um travel better and get places faster
you can
have better food we know we can have
better medical care if you know
unfortunately in this country that's how
it's like and you know it just allows us
to have
time and choices which is like it might
not be about you know for
a lot of people like it might not be
about a future artistic integrity it
also might be like
the power to be able to like leave a bad
relationship if you want to you know
it's being able to have future freedom
and that's time though so like how how i
spend my time
while i'm here that's
that's on me if i have the money to
support myself and my family and to do
whatever i need
then um i can if i start selling out
or doing things that are just for a
paycheck um i believe that
soon it will be one of the last
paychecks i cash so
if i'm just doing things that i like you
know even if it's
a it's a miss you know um it's something
that's fulfilling me in some way
i'm spending my time here the way that i
want to spend it
you know none of us get out of here
alive so you know
it's the truth oh why have i never
thought about that
before yeah i've never thought about it
that way
well none of us none of us do so it's
like while we're here
like make it count for you i mean it was
interesting i was talking to a friend of
mine the other day one of my best
friends from college
lizzie goodman brilliant journalist and
writer and she said something
i was like talking about something and i
couldn't make a choice and i was like
should i take this job or should i do
this thing and she just goes
well we're dying so what do you think
like it just was like oh my god we're
fucking dying i do feel like i should be
doing more
i feel that all the time yeah i should
be doing more i feel like i should be
doing more
activism i feel like i should be doing
more for my career i feel like i should
be doing more for my family i feel like
i should be doing more for my dogs i
feel like
i'm always feeling like i should i
should have done more i could have done
more
and i think that's because anxiety comes
over me and then i don't do stuff
and then when i finally feel like i can
do this then eventually this guilt comes
in
oh i wasted all that time before and i
wish i'd done this and it's like this
weird cycle and so now
it's like if i think about
my my girlfriends
who can't
be anxious over how much time they lost
anymore because it's just done
i you know want to learn that lesson
permanently that i need to to just
accept my time and accept everything
that's coming my way and just do the
best
just try my best i really feel like it's
the people that do the most that don't
think they do enough
it's always that it's always that it's
like the fact that you're sitting here
saying like i wish i could do more
meanwhile i know so many people that
haven't lifted a fucking figure
when it comes to anything you know and i
think that i think
you know we have to and it's so hard for
me to remember like we have to recharge
ourselves like in order to give like our
cup has to be full
you know like i always feel so guilty
taking care of myself i always feel so
guilty i mean benton knows i'm like
obsessed about my self-care and taking
naps and like you know protecting my
time and it's like so that i can
show up 100 in other ways and rescue
animals and whatever i do because i know
that i just i
can't be effective at it well you were
so good when we had those fires you know
and then instead of
malibu and i was just i was like i'm
gonna reach out to you and then i always
just know that i'm like okay i can do
this
but i sat there going i mean truth i was
like
thank god there's people like whitney
because i don't know
i'm frozen and i don't know what to do i
mean i'm here i mean
but i don't know i'm like but you are
the kind of person like with with the
fires you were like i'm gonna get my car
i don't know what the fuck i'm doing but
i'm gonna just
like you went right into it where for me
i'm like oh my god i don't know what to
do
i'll be here be available and that felt
like i was like god i wish i knew how to
you were so
awesome like this was uh for those of
you that don't know a couple years ago
well
it was last year there were huge fires
in
california and animals were trapped and
people's homes were lost i mean it was
just a nightmare and my thing is like
i'm not good at everything
but when the fires happened that is
where i shine like
like time of crisis animals like that's
what i know how to do like i grew up
with horses i'm a horse person like i
know how to get
horses on trailers like i know what to
do so
and i also was in a fire as a kid and
wow
to me a lot i haven't really talked
about that publicly but when
fire happens there's just like i'm just
in like you
tell that story it's a how old were you
it's such a
weird story i was about seven and
every night i slept in this nightgown
and
when people ask me they're like have you
always been into animals and you always
loved animals and i
i like never know when it started but
when i think of the story i realized i
was wearing a very long black t-shirt
that was like a
pajama t-shirt that said world wildlife
federation and it had animals on it and
i wore it
all the time like i was just already you
know i grew up like
you know sexual assault as a kid a lot
of times you connect to animals because
they're helpless and they're voiceless
and they're innocent
and it's just like a so maybe it was
that um i
grew up around a lot of alcoholics but
my aunts lived on a farm and
animals they don't lie they don't
manipulate they don't use you they don't
exploit you
like i just always connected with
animals and their innocence and their
integrity
so i remember because i was wearing that
and i'm not
i hope this doesn't get me any sympathy
i don't want it but
i remember my dad never paid the
electric bill like our family was very
much keeping up with the joneses it was
like have a nice car
but don't get groceries like spending
money on all the wrong things you know
like keeping up appearances but not like
taking care of the basics so it's like
the electricity bill wasn't paid
and it was the middle of winter and it
wasn't i didn't know at the time this
was weird you don't know what's weird
when you're a kid yeah you know it's
like i remember just going to friends
houses and being like whoa look at all
this shit in your fridge like what are
you what's all what is all this like why
would you have all this in here it's
gonna go bad like i just
you acclimate to your environment you
know and you make it work as a kid
and we never had heat so i know this is
gonna sound
totally crazy i was seven i would get i
would turn all the
burners up on the stove and i used to
get dressed on the stove every morning
because that was cold wow which is like
now that i look back
it's like crazy to think about and
um you were standing on the stove as the
burners run yeah i would turn the
burners on and then i would get dressed
for school on the stove
it sounds i know it's i know i had to i
had to ask because i feel like people
listening are like
she did what it sounds like you're
standing on top of a stove getting
dressed with the burners on
how are you standing on it if the
burner's wrong because there's four
burners and i would stand
in the middle i mean i caught a fire
went down so that's what happened
that's why you know i don't know how to
use a stove downstairs i have trauma
around stoves
well that's stuff downstairs good god
okay wait so then
so there were you know how like stoves
used to have four burners
yeah and i would turn the burners on and
start heating up the room
and then i would just like stand in the
middle and get dressed i was little
you know and i remember our cereal was
right above it so i would like stand on
the stove and like open it
and then one day the black t-shirt just
went up in flames
oh my god and i have like scars on my
legs and like burn scars and some on my
hands and stuff
and it was just it was what it was and
whatever
at the time you you don't know you're
being traumatized when you're being
traumatized
i think are you just jumping through the
fire part and it was what it was
anyway so trauma is very difficult by
the way it was we know about trump
we all get trauma okay blah blah blah
trauma trauma trauma it hurts you as an
adult you never get get over it
go back to the fire by the way that was
my first ulthera appointment
yeah i was like blah blah blah i know
i've got trauma anyways how do i lose
weight
this is why my face is so shiny
i kept catching on fire so wait your
thing catches on fire
you you cause because if you are a grown
woman with
with scar still that means it's a bad
fire that happened to you it was not
good
it was not good and the and basically
what happened was the thing caught on
fire
and then it sort of stuck to my legs so
i just
i remember there was black in my legs
from the t-shirt you know what i mean
and it was no big deal went to school
you know who put you out me
i just like figured it out that's why i
have burn scars on my hands
so for me like i grew up were you crying
no that wasn't really acceptable
did they kill you on the inside first i
mean it was it was really
were you scared i wasn't i grew up in a
really
dangerous environment where i have this
emotional dyslexia where really
dangerous situations i feel comfortable
and safe in
and then really safe environments i get
because it's not what you grew up i get
antsy yeah and a lot of people that grew
up in that sort of like so for me for
the longest time just hanging out
one-on-one with a safe person made me
anxious i'm like
because you're always waiting for the
shoe to drop right but when the shoes
already dropped you don't have to worry
i feel comfortable it feels comfortable
because your
disposition is fight or flight that's
everything has to go up here and you're
like oh
then you're like cruising out there was
a fire i was like yes
i'm chilling like i know what to do i
know and for me it's like
i know what the enemy is i know what i'm
fighting no one can gaslight me about
this like it's
very clear that this is the problem that
needs to be solved yeah whereas for me i
struggle in the uncertainty of life of
is this bad is this person bad am i
supposed to be doing this do i trust
this person it's like everything is so
ambiguous
but when there's a very clear villain
it's just like
i know what to do i know where i'm
supposed to be i spend so much of my
life being like am i supposed to be here
am i supposed to be doing this am i
supposed to be working harder at this
there's no uncertainty when there's a
fire and there's something so
calming about that to me because i know
exactly where my body's supposed to be i
know exactly who the bad guy is
and i know what the truth is there's no
ambiguous truth
so i remember as soon as the fire
happened i started driving out to the
fire
and it was so weird that no it was so
weird to me that no one was going in
that direction
i remember there being like no one on
the road and being like how come
everyone's not
running into the burning building like i
am wait just to be clear when you caught
on fire the child you
caught on fire and then you what twirled
around and were in your school clothes
right just like i just like cinderella
yeah you just burnt the clothes right
off of you like
yeah that's the lowest scar wow um the
fact that you just
that means there's such a really bad
bird you didn't even go to the hospital
no
no we didn't do that what are we what
what am i
marie antoinette no one what am i well
they killed what did i grow up in
versailles
no one else no one at the school was
like what happened yes i got sent home
from school so i went to school
there we go and the teacher saw it and
we're like you're going to the office
and that was the first like you're going
to the office
and we're making calls and you're you're
a different kid
you're a kid that's like a problem you
know or like your parents are a problem
or whatever it was and that was the
beginning of my
fear of embarrassment and being
different and feeling like i was
um my biggest nightmare was being
embarrassed which a lot of
people theorize that the reason people
become comedians is to control the way
they're embarrassed
so um so the fires it was like it was
you know
i'm also a fucking adrenaline junkie i
don't really drink i don't really
use drugs like this that's my you need
fight or flight you're trying to put
yourself back into that that's right
just i
i feel the most awake alive
and good about myself when i am solving
a problem that i'm sure is a problem
so a lot of times i've spent a lot of my
life solving problems that weren't real
like men and people and trying to like
fix people's lives and solve problems
that i created myself
for just like but like solving a real
problem
is uh you know when it comes to like the
animal stuff i'm like
i go out of body like i disassociate and
kind of as crazy as this sounds like i
just say what i think the animal would
say if they could talk yeah you know and
there's an a giraffe in malibu that
wasn't evacuated they didn't have a
trailer for it they're not feeding it
the right food they don't have a license
for it it's all fucking illegal it's all
abuse and like
i saw horses with gashes you know they
were ripped open at this fucking
saddle rock ranch malibu wines place and
i went ape shit
and yeah you know and so i just um
i don't i it's just very clear to me
that when someone abuses an animal like
what are you doing to women and children
well yeah you know if this is just what
we see
like what the fuck is going on behind
the scenes you know and so i just like i
don't like liars and i don't like
um anyone that abuses animals like
you're just
it's a non-starter for me yeah that's
like when you go if if i get taken
you're like
whatever happens that it like you
it's okay i i trust it's there's
something like
yeah it's so true like i i mean if i see
someone abusing their dog like
i will fight with you till i can t i'm
taking it
like i have a hammer in my car to smash
windows of people that leave their dogs
in hot cars like i'm just that bitch
and like i don't see the world i just
can't imagine it any other way
you know yeah it's just so clear to me
that that that is
and it's intolerable for me not to i
can't tolerate it like if i see a dog in
a hot car
like i'm smashing the window i had a
therapist tell me once he said
you know it's interesting when it comes
to
activism your career your friendships
you're extremely clear when it comes to
relationships you get very unclear what
is that
yeah i think it's like an overdeveloped
sense of
for me responsibility and compassion
where i think i need to rescue people
and have the same amount of forgiveness
and patience for people that i do for
animals
whereas like if i am dealing with a dog
that comes from a dog fighting situation
and they're nippy or they're barking or
they're aggressive i forgive them i'm
like i know exactly why you're the way
you are of course you're like this
you're scared this is all fear like it's
so clear to me what's going on
and then i take that over to humans and
i'm like
no you're 40. yeah you could have gone
to therapy you could have fucking fixed
this i don't need to be radically
accepting
yeah of your rage you should not be
yelling at me in a parking lot you're 45
years old
like pull it together like i'm overly
forgiving when it comes to
men and i also in relationships i think
i have this um
really uh just the fucking it's it's
like disney 101 i have this thing where
it's like
i'm a weirdo if i'm not in a
relationship i'm a spinster
i've failed like there's just like that
shit
that comes up too which has just taken a
long time to deprogram for me the
pressure of like well i have to be with
someone
so i might as well be in something bad
being in something bad is better than
being alone
well yeah it seems like it's like the
the certain shitty path is much better
than the uncertain path
yeah you're like oh so this one this one
is for sure shitty but i but i'm going
this direction and i'll
i'll eventually successfully die and
then okay but this one could be
happiness
but we're not sure but it could be some
bumps i mean but there's more
happiness over here but there's going to
be some i don't know what those bumps
are i don't i don't know i don't like
and then you start doing math and i'm
not good at math so then i'm like
by the time i leave this person and then
i meet a new person that's going to be
in two years and
they're they're going to suck too so i
might as well just like stick with this
person
and it's just like it's fucking hassle
you know what i mean
oh that's why i don't do math yeah don't
just stay away
stay away from the math um i love you so
much i love you so much
wait i have one last question okay
i end these super awkwardly but you're
not gonna let me um
what are some of the other things that
you thought of me back that you
projected on to me i don't feel you ever
finished
it can i have a cashew can i eat a
cashew yes just so you know the fans are
gonna
if they're almonds the fans get upset
why they don't like because
they just sound very like they're like
an audio nightmare i guess
there you go you're leaning back i was
jealous of you
when we they don't hate it that much i
[Music]
i'm not doing anything you don't have to
leave the room or anything i
when i first met you and first learned
about you
or like saw you i would see you at like
meetings or
like auditions or parties or something i
was definitely jealous but in the
beginning
i think i was more
sorry when i start laughing i can't see
i'm not jealous of you now
how the mighty have fallen your fucking
mess
i'm so comfortable that's nuts this is
confident it does not know
you were just this put together like
classy beautiful
like feminine just like portrait of
perfection
with no ostensible flaws
still none
[Music]
do you really want to do this i 100
there's nothing else i want to do right
now okay
so i'll tell you the time i'll tell you
the time well
i do i have a really horrible habit of
like laughing
and spitting out nuts and well anything
any of my mouth
okay i also remember seeing you at ally
larder's house
and you were wearing jean cut off shorts
and you looked so fucking cool really
you're wearing jean cut off shorts like
that goal all the time and like look
cool and like a long cardigan
and i remember being like this bitch wow
like
jean shorts and a long cardigan i never
would have thought of that
what's sad is that like that's still
what i'm rocking i haven't changed it
doesn't i don't think it's at school now
but it like blew my
mind and you were so every party i've
ever seen you on i go in like there's
like five people standing in a circle
around you and you're just making them
laugh and being hilarious
and just like so cl this is my
projection of you
as an insecure person who's like walking
into a party like all scared that you're
just like holding court and making
everybody laugh and everyone's like
waiting in line to talk to you and i'm
like
an ogre in the corner like that's just
and she's so confident and can like just
walk into a party and talk to anybody
and them that's crazy that's such a i
wish that i hope that everybody else
looks at me like that i hope that that's
the same
but i don't think they do and it was
like a like uh it was just like in a mix
of intimidation and awe
and i don't get intimidated by people i
don't really give a shit i just remember
being like i don't have an
in with like i don't know how to and
then i always was like we
i always thought like we should be
friends but she can wear a cardigan and
i don't know how to do that
if you have a cashew right on your lips
fine good i'm building my brand
i have flaws i'm authentic it doesn't
matter i'm not perfect
fucking put you know what do it with
your pussy out that little that thing
that hangs out that you said
this is what it looks like it's about
this bitch no yours looks like
this is what my vagina looks like no
yours probably looks like it's more like
it is kind of true no that is what it
looks like you know hers looks like this
no what is that a growth no that's even
sticks out
mine no it's like your vagina is like
this it's like that
no it's like
it is like no it's like this
what no no no if my lips are your vagina
lips this is your thing
why does my vagina have like a weird
skin tag on it why can't
it's round this is based off your
description it literally looks like this
i'm not even kidding but you have to
look at it upside down hold on
can you see this why are we trying to
get in the mic
as if hold on you know i'm trying to get
in the camera so you're seeing it
you're looking at me like this i feel
like i should just step out and take the
call from your publicist now
they don't even know i'm doing this
i just ate your vagina that's probably a
good thing all right
if i'm going to get a very stern email
from them tomorrow so you want veneers
you like your teeth but you're giving
them the ears what are you gonna do
you have i'm gonna i'm gonna go on
record you have
maybe my favorite set of teeth really
yeah you have really good
yeah you guys there's some of them are
crooked on them no that's why that's why
oh wow i agree somebody said once like
one person on twitter that i think i
remember they're like
olivia went and got like veneers and i
was like no i didn't but thank you for
that that's when people tell me i got
plastic surgery i'm like thank you so
much
in magic mike um there's a shot of me
it's like
um after channing and i my you know our
characters had sex and then the
the camera's coming up this way and i
was watching that in the premiere
and i had no idea i remember a long time
ago dentist told me like well your teeth
on on top they're a bit crooked if you
wanted to fix that but i thought he's
talking about the ones on the side that
i was like i'm fine with that
i don't mind he's like okay but then i
saw with this weird shadow
my teeth up here like one goes in more
and if you need to go back and watch it
and it just looks like
i got just a crooked fence in my mouth
my my i have this one tooth
and i was on invisalign forever this one
tooth
i know it looks like nothing and i don't
talk about it much because i don't want
to be like i'm the person like pointing
out my flaws like i
i'm i'm good but i noticed it it's that
too i'm just kidding
it's this one it distracts from the
lines on my neck this one
in certain photos like on red carpets it
looks like i'm missing this tooth
like it casts a weird shadow and it
looks like i'm missing a tooth
so i haven't been wearing my invisalign
but
have you ever seen people whose teeth
don't line up with their nose like this
part doesn't line up
never thought about it no no it's all
i'm going to think about here
whoa i know i noticed when people's
eyebrows don't line up with this part of
their eye
like your eyebrow is supposed to if you
take a pen here it's supposed to start
here it's supposed to yes so i used to
pluck my eyebrows like to hear and it
makes you look crazy but it's supposed
to line up to here i do notice symmetry
of eyebrows
but that's really it but i have wild
teeth you have good teeth your teeth are
like your teeth are excellent i like
this one little snaggletooth on the
right
don't call us oh sorry like this one
right here
is so good i hate it when people do that
they're like i love the
your imperfections like i love how your
teeth just started
they started insulting you it's like
people say to me they'll be like whitney
like the backhand of conflicts would be
like i love that you like don't even
care what you look like i'm like
i actually do thank you i love you
actually you don't even care what you
wear i'm like yeah i put a lot of
thought and effort into this but thank
you
why can't we say things that you know
you can't like i know you're not
supposed to like nitpicking but about
like
things that it's not like it's obnoxious
for you to if you were like i'm fat
because you're not fat
but like it should be okay that we're
like i don't like this like my you know
that my
teeth look like this yes it should be
okay like without people being like oh
you're body shaming yourself and you're
hurting us because i have that same
crooked tooth it's like so what your
crooked tooth looks nice
does not i also i'm grandfathered in i'm
37.
i'm allowed to not like myself i didn't
have the inspirational quotes i didn't
have
jay shetty whatever i didn't have all
the
like i get to still have low self-esteem
well that's a little far i don't have
low self-esteem
you know what i i what i realized
something the
difference between low self-esteem and
low self-worth just interesting
inch very interesting because i think
low self-worth will keep you in
um relationships that you shouldn't be
in
unlike but like but you can have high
self-esteem and low self-worth that's
right and you can have a lot of
confidence and low self-esteem
mm-hmm i just ate one nut and look how
much smarter i got
no and i think it's important that
people realize with this self-esteem i
always want to say
remind people when people are like well
how do you like get high self-esteem
you have to do esteemable actions so
it's also like a daily thing like a
steam you don't just like have it or you
don't
work you can build it over time and you
can't stay clean on the shower you took
yesterday like what are you doing today
for others to build your self-esteem and
self-worth you know
and that's like a daily practice wow i
didn't know that yeah it seems
exhausting you're not just like i have
self-esteem and i'm done i'm fixed
it's like every day like what are you
doing like lying corrodes your
self-esteem selfish actions corrode your
self-esteem gossip corrodes your
self-esteem like these are things that
actively attack like death by a thousand
cups
your self-esteem and saying no to things
that are beneath you
builds your self-esteem like who's i
talking to um oh yeah was that that
person that was like she's like i don't
know if i should go on this thing or not
and i don't know and i was like say no
to something that is abusive to you or
destructive to you because that's how
you build your self-worth
when you stand up for yourself then you
have get to have pride and self-esteem
all right i love you we're gonna hang
out don't ride elephants adopt don't
shop you know the deal
like comment subscribe oh jesus awesome
also can you also throw in don't swim
with dolphins in hotels
yeah i don't i mean in hotels you know
in all those fancy hotels it was like
swim with dolphins
those dolphins have been captured and
they like live their life in these like
you cannot you're late to that don't
don't do that yeah yeah don't do that
that's like one of the most horrible
don't film with dolphins we're adding
that don't worry
yes sorry i know it's hard to have a lot
and if you've already done it
that's okay just don't do it again yeah
and then take your pictures down so
don't promote it
yeah yeah exactly right also we have a
lot of special treats coming out later
you'll see them in the merch store
oh god y'all have a merch store yeah
yeah you want some merch what's in the
merch
excuse me i want to know i want to see
what you all are making how like
swampy i am what we're making love you
guys thank you
oh wait that's we're going
[Applause]